Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast mit der ESA und dem DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und heute geht es um, ja, heute geht es um eine ganz, ganz praktische Anwendung der Raum, der Raumzeit wollte ich gerade sagen, der Raumfahrt. Ja, etwas, was viele von uns wahrscheinlich auch schon mal selber auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise genutzt haben, nämlich die Satellitennavigation. Und um da mal etwas Handfestes zu erfahren, bin ich wieder in Oberpfaffenhofen gelandet, beim DLR, genauer beim Institut für Kommunikation und Navigation, und begrüße als Gesprächspartner den Felix, Felix Andreich. Hallo.
Hallo.
Ja, du bist bei dem genannten Institut tätig, schon eine Weile, oder?
Ich bin seit 2003 hier.
Seit 2003. Und, wie ist das so?
Macht viel Spaß.
Und was ist jetzt konkret deine Aufgabe im Wesentlichen in dem Institut?
Ich bin wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter und arbeite in verschiedenen internationalen und nationalen Projekten. Und auf der anderen Seite habe ich noch die Aufgabe, Forschung zu machen oder die Freude, Forschung zu machen. Ich habe in parallel meine Dissertation geschrieben hier. Die ist jetzt endlich fertig und ich bin kurz davor, abzugeben. Warte noch auf mein, das letzte Okay von meinem Professor.
Was ist das Thema?
Das Thema ist Kanalschätzung oder Parameterschätzung mit Multi-Antennensystemen. Und es gibt zwei Themen. Und das zweite Thema ist Signaldesign für GNSS-Systeme. Also Global Navigation Satellite Systems.
Genau, wo wir quasi schon beim Thema wären.
Also es gibt da zwei Teile in der Arbeit, aber beide Teile haben miteinander zu tun, weil natürlich der Empfänger verarbeitet das Signal und auf der anderen Seite möchte ich ein Signal entwerfen, was ich auch gut abstrahlen kann und eben auch gute Empfangseigenschaften habe.
Und was für eine Ausbildung ist dem vorangegangen, dass das so auf so einen Weg geführt hat?
Ich habe Elektrotechnik und Informationstechnik an der TU München studiert.
Und war da schon Raumfahrt von vornherein das Thema eigentlich? War das so immer schon das Ziel?
Es hat mich immer interessiert. Es gab auch einige Vorlesungen, sogar von hier, vom Kollegen vom DLR, vom Professor Lutz zu Satellitenkommunikation. Aber sonst hatten wir relativ wenig Kontakt mit Raumfahrt. Das hat sich jetzt stark verbessert, weil unser Institutsleiter, der Professor Günther, ist jetzt auch Professor an der TU München und hat da auch eine Vorlesung zu Satellitennavigation. Und ich glaube, das hat sehr geholfen. Also wir haben schon einige neue Mitarbeiter auch über diese Vorlesungen praktisch bekommen, die sich da für das Thema begeistert haben.
Da zeigt sich eigentlich, dass so die Forschungsinstitute und die Universitäten gut zusammenarbeiten sollten.
Ja, ist sehr, sehr wichtig.
Und den Fluss da auch herzustellen.
Also wir brauchen das auch, weil die meisten Leute bei uns ja auch promovieren wollen und die brauchen natürlich jemanden, der die Promotion durchführt. Und das kann nur die Universität und eben auch den Abschluss vergibt. Und das kann eben nur die Universitäts-DLR kann das nicht. Und da ist ganz wichtig, sind die Kontakte zu den Universitäten. Deshalb sind auch viele Abteilungsleiter teilweise und Institutsleiter, Professoren an Universitäten, um diesen Kontakt zu festigen.
Sozusagen Win-Win auf beiden Seiten.
Ja, das ist ganz wichtig.
Ja, Institut für Kommunikation und Navigation, globale Satelliten-Systeme. Da werden sicherlich einige schon auf das tolle Wort gekommen sein. Galileo, das große Projekt der Europäer, ein Satelliten-Navigationssystem zu bauen. Da werden wir auch im Einzelnen noch drauf eingehen. Aber das ist sozusagen auch dein Feld mit.
Wir sind da sehr stark beteiligt in Teilen der Entwicklung des Systems, aber auch hauptsächlich in der Entwicklung von Empfangsgeräten. Also meine Gruppe arbeitet hauptsächlich in der Entwicklung von Empfangsgeräten und Strategien. Also wir bauen natürlich keine Geräte. Das Maximale, was wir tun, ist Prototypen aufzubauen, um Wege zu zeigen. Wir sind hauptsächlich, wir verkaufen ja keine, wir sind ein Forschungsinstitut. Aber es geht darum, einen sogenannten Proof of Concept zu erbringen für verschiedene Dinge, die wir uns ausdenken. Und dann möchte man eben kurz demonstrieren vielleicht in einem praktischen Szenario, ob diese Dinge auch wirklich funktionieren. Also das ist der Weg, den wir maximal bestreiten.
Ja, globale Navigationssysteme, ich meine, dass es einen Navigationsbedarf gibt und vor allem auch ein Navigationsproblem. Das ist ja nichts Neues. Ich denke, das geht zurück im Prinzip auf die guten Zeiten der Schifffahrt, wo die Europäer ausgesetzt haben, mal den Rest des Planeten zu erkunden und sich da ja schon allerlei haben einfallen lassen. Ich weiß gar nicht, was so im Einzelnen für Strategien sich so über die Zeit da entwickelt haben. Am bekanntesten dürfte natürlich so das Segel nach den Sternen sein, weil das ist natürlich das Einzige, was man im Prinzip so überall vorgefunden hat, und was ja auch weitgehend stabil war. Und dann eben die Arbeit mit den Sechstanten. Tatsächlich machen ja auch die Satelliten, wie wir jetzt hier zum Beispiel in der Sendung Missionsplanung etc. gehört haben, machen ja eigentlich auch nichts anderes, als dass sie die ganze Zeit die anderen Sterne beobachten, um sich ihre eigenen Position zu vergewissern. Aber die Satelliten-Navigationssysteme haben im Prinzip einen komplett neuen Ansatz gefahren. Ja, die Amerikaner mit dem GPS-System, was ja jeder kennt, waren da im Prinzip ganz weit vorne. Was, weiß gar nicht, kann man sagen, was die sozusagen auf die die Spur gebracht hat? Ich meine, gab es da mal irgendwie so ein Ideen-Urknall oder war das immer schon total naheliegend und schon als sie die erste Rakete hochgeschickt haben, wussten sie, ach.
Gut, das kann ich jetzt schlecht sagen, was die Amerikaner wirklich bewegt hat. Ich habe den Eindruck, dass es ist ein militärisch betriebenes System. Das System wird vom Department of Defense und der US Air Force betrieben. Das sind also rein militärische Beweggründe gewesen, die hinter dem System standen. Eventuell auch oder Dinge, die mit den Interkontinentalraketen zusammenhängen, dass man eben die sicher ins Ziel bringen möchte. Und dass da natürlich über diese langen Strecken, die diese Flugkörper zurücklegen, so ein System sehr hilfreich sein kann. Aber das ist eine reine Spekulation. Es ist ein rein militärisches System. Am Anfang gewesen, es wurde eigentlich erst geöffnet für private Nutzer oder öffentliche Nutzer um 2000-2002 rum. Da wurde die sogenannte Selective Availability abgeschalten. Die Amerikaner haben vorsätzlich einen ihrer Services verschlechtert, so dass man ihn nicht nutzen kann oder nicht gut nutzen kann für die Navigation. Und das haben sie abgeschalten. Und deshalb gab es eigentlich auch bei uns diesen Boom mit diesen Navigationsgeräten. Das war sehr, sehr interessant zu sehen. Also es war ja auch kurz nachdem ich hier angefangen habe oder kurz vorher und danach hat man dann plötzlich gesehen, dass da in den Geschäften plötzlich solche Geräte angeboten wurden, wobei das System schon seit 92 als operativ galt.
Ich frage nochmal ein bisschen anders, was sozusagen den technischen Urknall da betrifft. Also was waren sozusagen die Technologien, die haben erst mal reifen müssen oder wo ein bestimmtes Verständnis vorliegen musste, um GPS überhaupt zu ermöglichen? Also was sind sozusagen die Kernideen und die Kernkomponenten und die kernwissenschaftlichen Erkenntnisse, die all diesen globalen, also was muss sozusagen, was musste erst mal da sein, um so etwas wie GPS machen zu können?
Also ich denke hauptsächlich die Satellitentechnologie musste so weit entwickelt werden, dass das möglich war. Meiner Meinung nach auch diese hochgenauen Uhren, die verwendet werden. Weil die Referenzzeit von GPS und auch die, das spielt eine sehr, sehr wichtige Rolle in der Positionierung. Also je genauer meine Zeitskala ist und je genauer die auch gehalten wird, desto genauer ist auch meine meine Position später.
Wie genau ist denn die Uhr?
Oh Gott, das weiß ich nicht genau.
Also ich meine, Größenordnungsmäßig. Verdammt irre, unglaublich genau?
Verdammt irre, unglaublich genau.
Also so drei Stellen nach dem Komma reicht da nicht aus.
Nein, das reicht nicht. Die geht irgendwie in eine Million Jahre irgendwie dann weniger als eine Sekunde falsch oder so. Ich kann nichts genaues dazu sagen. Aber es ist verdammt irre. Genau.
Verdammt irre, genau. Okay, also ich meine, wie funktioniert das? Was musste von den Amerikanern für eine Infrastruktur aufgebaut werden? Und wie spielt diese Infrastruktur zusammen, bis man wirklich in der Lage war, daraus eine konkrete Position eines beliebigen Objektes irgendwo auf dem Planeten zu ermitteln?
Also sie brauchen natürlich erstmal eine Menge Satelliten. Also es sind insgesamt bis zu 30. Operativ sind einige weniger. Das schwankt über die Jahre. Also es sind irgendwie 28, 26 operativ. Und die anderen? Die anderen sind sozusagen Backup. Falls mal was kaputt geht. Teilweise werden die eingeschalten und ausgeschalten. Da wird gewechselt, je nachdem was gebraucht wird. Je nachdem, wie sie auch neue Satelliten schießen, wie da die Planung ist. Ganz wichtig ist dann, zu den Satelliten brauch ich natürlich ein Bodensystem. Das Bodensystem muss eigentlich permanent alle Satelliten im Blick haben. Und zwar muss ich einerseits, habe ich am Boden meine Referenzzeit. Also ich habe am Boden ein Haus, sozusagen, da stehen lauter hochgenaue Uhren drin. Und die liefern mir eine Referenzzeit. Und die wird an die Satelliten sozusagen übertragen über das Bodensystem. Die Satelliten haben selber nochmal hochgenaue Uhren an Bord und vergleichen das ab. Und das ist eine wichtige Komponente, weil ich muss wissen, also der Empfänger muss genau wissen, wann hat der Satellit das abgeschickt, seine Nachricht. Der Empfänger misst dann ganz genau, wann ist das angekommen. Und die Differenz gibt einem dann den Abstand über die Ausbreitungsgeschwindigkeit des Signals. Und damit kann ich den Abstand bestimmen. Also das ist genauso, wie wenn ich auf der Straße zwei Striche mache und ich starte, ich laufe los, drücke auf meine Uhr, die Uhr läuft los, und ich drücke wieder auf meine Stoppuhr, wenn ich den zweiten Strich erhalten habe. Und dann kann ich, wenn ich weiß, wie schnell ich gelaufen bin, dann weiß ich, wie lange, dann weiß auch der Läufer, wie lange er dazwischen gebraucht hat.
Aber was machen jetzt die Satelliten genau? Also wo fliegen die lang?
Es gibt für GPS glaube ich sechs Bahnen, wo die drauf die Erde umkreisen.
Und das heißt mehrere auf einer Bahn hintereinander?
Hintereinander. In so einem Abstand, dass wenn man irgendwo steht, dass ich halt immer, also es wird so optimiert, dass ich, man nennt das eine gute Konstellation, zu jeder Zeit oder zu meisten Zeiten sehen kann. Da werden die Bahnen so ausgerichtet, dass die Erde gut abgedeckt ist. Also ich brauche nämlich nicht nur einen Satelliten natürlich um zu navigieren, sondern ich brauche eigentlich mindestens, im Dreidimensionalen brauche ich mindestens drei Quellen eigentlich für Navigation, für Satellitennavigation vier Quellen, um die Position zu berechnen. Also ich brauche vier Satelliten mindestens, um meine Position zu bestimmen.
Also die ich sehe, sozusagen.
Ja.
Und wir reden hier auch wirklich von Line of Sight, also Sicht sichtbar.
Ja, ich muss Sicht, mehr oder weniger, wenn ich sie sehe, also man kann sie natürlich nicht sehen, aber ich muss direkten Kontakt haben.
Und was darf da nicht dazwischen sein?
Es dürfen zum Beispiel keine Häuser dazwischen sein. Das ist zum Beispiel in der Stadt sehr, sehr kompliziert. Da haben wir dann irre Schwierigkeiten. Da gibt es große Schwierigkeiten, mit Satellitennavigationen ordentlich zu arbeiten. Da wird sehr viel dran gearbeitet, das besser hinzubekommen. Was man eben auch Probleme hat, sind in der Ausbreitung generell, habe ich natürlich noch eine obere Atmosphärenschicht, die mir mein Signal verändern. Die muss ich kennen, sehr, sehr genau. Ich habe untere Atmosphärenschichten, zum Beispiel Regen beeinflusst das Signal auch ein bisschen in seiner Leistung. Dann habe ich Effekte, die in der Nahumgebung des Empfängers eine sehr große Rolle spielen. Das sind Mehrwege-Ausbreitungen. Ich mache eine Laufzeitmessung. Ich will eigentlich bloß die Laufzeit des Signals von dem Satelliten bis zu meinem Empfänger bestimmen. Dann wird das Signal sozusagen an Quellen in meiner nahen Umgebung reflektiert. Es gibt praktisch mehrere Echoes, wie beim Schall auch. Das beeinflusst meine Laufzeitmessung negativ. Ich habe das Signal mehrfach. Manche Pfade haben länger gebraucht als der direkte Pfad. Da habe ich Probleme.
Bevor wir uns mit den potentiellen Problemen noch durcheinanderbringen, bleiben wir erst mal bei dem Idealbild. Man hat jetzt sechs Bahnen. Das heißt, die überschneiden sich auch. Das heißt, sie sind dann auf unterschiedlicher Höhe. Oder sind die so, dass sie sich nur nicht treffen?
Die treffen sich nicht.
Na ja, gut. Davon gehe ich natürlich aus. Aber treffen die sich nicht, weil sie nie beide am selben Kreuzungspunkt sind oder haben sie unterschiedliche Höhe?
Ich glaube, sie haben leicht unterschiedliche Höhen auch.
In der Sicherheit. Okay, und das heißt, die fliegen da so lang und sind fix unterwegs. Und in welcher Höhe sind die so üblicherweise unterwegs?
Das sind ungefähr 25.000 bis 30.000 Kilometer.
Also, schon relativ weit weg, aber halt noch nicht beim geostationären Orbit, sondern sozusagen sind dann aber auch so ziemlich die... Ist da noch was unterwegs in diesem Bereich?
Oder ist das so dieser typische... Oh ja, da ist viel, viel unterwegs, ja.
Jetzt fliegen die 30 Dinger da lang und sie kriegen, das heißt, immer wenn sie diese, diese eine Boden, also es gibt eine Bodenstation, die diese zentrale Uhr generiert.
Es gibt zwei, die diese zentralen Uhren haben, es gibt noch viele weitere Stationen, die permanent mit den Satelliten in Kontakt sind. Also ich muss, wichtig ist ja, ich muss am Empfänger ja auch die Position des Satelliten kennen. Die muss er mir mitteilen, damit ich die Laufzeit... Ja, der zahlt sie mir mit, indem er, er schickt mir ein Signal. Mit diesem Signal mache ich eine Laufzeitmessung und der Satellit teilt mir auch noch mit, was er gerade für eine Position hat. Und mit dieser Information, mit der Laufzeit, dann weiß ich den Abstand und ich weiß, wenn ich die Position des Satelliten habe, dann weiß ich relativ, dann kann ich meine Position damit berechnen, wenn ich vier Satelliten habe und diese Laufzeitmessungen mache.
Okay, lass uns noch kurz bei dem Satelliten bleiben. Also jetzt nur sozusagen, ich bin der Satellit, was tue ich? Also ich brauche sozusagen in dem Moment, wo ich jetzt im Orbit bin, ich flieg da so rum, wie ich hab so meine ganzen Partner-Satelliten auf der gleichen Bahn, bzw. fünf andere und die anderen sind auf irgendwelchen anderen Bahnen und passen gut auf, dass sie mit mir nicht in Kondition geraten. So, und jetzt mit wem kommuniziere ich? Also was, ist das jetzt sozusagen diese eine primäre Bodenstation oder bin ich permanent mit irgendeiner Bodenstation?
Ich bin permanent mit einer Boden, mit einer der Bodenstationen in Verbindung.
Okay, und was erzählt die mir?
Die Bodenstation erzählt mir, was ich abzustrahlen habe.
Also in Form von Zeit?
In Form von Zeit und in Form von Position, weil der Satellit selber weiß nicht, wo er ist. Ach. Der kriegt das von der Bodenstation mitgeteilt.
Laufend.
Das heißt, während ich der Satellit die Erde umkreise, erzählt mir die ganze Zeit irgendjemand, wo ich bin.
Sagt x ist das, y ist das, z ist das.
Das heißt, das Ding ist selber eigentlich ein relativ dummes Gerät. Man guckt nicht in die Sterne, das misst nicht die eigene Geschwindigkeit oder so, sondern er kriegt einfach die ganze Zeit nur gesagt, du bist jetzt da.
Ja, der ist nicht ganz dumm. Der muss natürlich immer, was er macht, er guckt zum Beispiel auch auf die Sterne und auch auf die Sonne, weil er muss sich immer wieder ausrichten, das macht er automatisch auf die Erde.
Also er fliegt auf seiner Bahn.
Genau, das macht er schon, das ist aber relativ, das kriegt er nicht gesagt von unten. Also er macht einige Dinge automatisch, also das was den Nutzer interessiert, also er muss natürlich immer auf die Erde schauen und hat einen gewissen Winkel, in dem er sein Signal abstrahlt auf die Erde und damit das immer optimal ist, damit möglichst viel Leistung auf der Erde ankommt, das wird automatisch gesteuert, da gibt es eine automatische Steuerung. Dazu nutzt er die Sterne, soweit ich weiß, und auch die Sonne teilweise, um sich da zu orientieren, wo er denn hin zeigen soll. Er versucht auch einige Geräte, die bei ihm an Bord sind, weg von der Sonne zu drehen, damit die nicht besonders heiß werden. Solche Dinge macht er. Aber was er abstrahlt, das kriegt er eigentlich permanent von unten gesagt.
Das heißt aber, woher weiß denn jetzt die Bodenstationen, wo die sind?
Ja, die machen das umgekehrte Problem. Da hat man mehrere Empfänger am Boden, wo ich weiß, wo die sind. Und ich kann dann, indem ich an diesen Bodenstationen das Satellitensignal gleichzeitig empfange und diese Laufzeitmessungen mache, habe ich drei Abstände von verschiedenen Positionen und dann kann ich, wo diese Geraden sich schneiden, da ist der Satellit dann.
Das heißt, die Position der Satelliten, die die Satelliten später dem eigentlichen Endnutzer zukommen lassen will, muss ich eigentlich selber auf dieselbe Art und Weise erst mal errechnen aus diesen Daten. Das heißt, dieses Teil sendet quasi die ganze Zeit so ein Ich Bin, und meine Vorstellung von Zeit ist diese. Und das macht er auf so einen großen Kreis, oder keine Ahnung, ob ihr seht, was das für eine Form ist. Was hat das für einen Durchmesser?
Dann wird fast die halbe Erde abgestrahlt.
Also fast alles, was er da irgendwie so sieht, was war das, 25.000 Kilometer, da hat man ja das ja schon ganz guter Blickwinkel. Okay, genau. Das heißt, er betupft sozusagen die komplette Oberfläche mit seinen Informationen. Und da, wo die ganzen Bodenstationen sind, die die sozusagen da auch mit Beauftragten befugt sind, empfangen dieses Signal, wissen natürlich selbst, wo sie sind und können dann sozusagen unter der Annahme A, wir wissen, der fliegt jetzt so und so schnell und das irgendwie da und da und das ist der und der und die Uhrzeit ist, mhm, durch sozusagen dieses Vorbeiziehen genau sagen, wo er ist.
Genau.
Und wenn das er errechnet ist, was sozusagen wahrscheinlich so die ganze Zeit laufen, das läuft auch die ganze Zeit, genau, wird ihm das parallel die ganze Zeit auch gesendet. Das heißt, es ist nicht so ein, alle 5 Minuten wird ihm mal erzählt, wo er ist, sondern er erhält quasi permanent von der Bodenstation so ein Signal.
Ja gut, er, es wird diese, es wird schon nicht permanent ihm gesendet, also er behält diese, ich weiß nicht, wie lange diese Message gültig ist, aber das wird immer nur in Schritten ab, also in Schritten.
Größenordnung, so was weiß ich, 5 Minuten?
Das sind 12, 10 Minuten. Ah, okay. Das System kann auch autark laufen für eine gewisse Zeit. Also es wurde gebaut, um auch...
Das heißt, der Satellit ist schon so intelligent, dass wenn er einmal die Position mitgeteilt bekommen hat, dass er sich sozusagen selber ausdenken kann, okay, ich bin jetzt auf dieser Bahn, ich bin so schnell unterwegs, in einer Minute bin ich vermutlich da und dann stimmt das auch weitgehen. Okay. Das heißt, die Bodenstationen korrigieren sozusagen eigentlich eher die selbst...
Ja, greift korrigierend ein immer wieder.
So, das heißt, der Satellit wird jetzt quasi mit Informationen betankt, permanent und immer wieder korrigiert, aber das Einzige, was er eigentlich wirklich weiß, ist die Zeit und wo er ist. Und was für ein Koordinatensystem ist das da? Also ich meine, was muss man denn da wissen? Der Abstand zur Erde ist mehr oder weniger konstant. Das heißt, das ist einfach so eine Position auf so einer dreidimensionalen Kugel. Wahrscheinlich irgendwas mit Vektoren und Abständen und so weiter. Viele griechische Buchstaben, ja. Und das wird jetzt alles sozusagen in diese eigentliche Endkundenbotschaft hineinkodiert?
Genau, die sogenannte Navigationsnachricht kriegt man da geschickt.
Wie viele Daten sind das?
Das ist nicht besonders viel, was man da bekommt. Man bekommt eben diese Satelliten-Positionen und diese Zeitskala-Korrektur. Ja, das war's dann eigentlich schon. Verschiedene andere Korrekturdaten noch. Aber das muss sehr genau eben übertragen werden.
Und hat da jeder Satellit dann einen anderen Frequenzbereich, den er verwendet? Oder empfange ich alle auf derselben Frequenz?
Ich empfange alle auf, für GPS, alle auf der gleichen Frequenz. Die sind dann durch verschiedene Codes getrennt. Das heißt, jeder Satellit hat einen Code zugewiesen. Und durch diese Codes kann ich sie trennen. Kann auch der Empfänger sie dann trennen.
Also trennen im Sinne von, dass ich weiß, wer ihr zu mir gesprochen hat.
Und für wen ich jetzt gerade die Laufzeitmessung mache.
Und dass die nicht alle gleichzeitig senden, das stellen die Satelliten selber sicher.
Sie senden alle gleichzeitig, haben aber verschiedene Codes.
Kurz jetzt reden wir jetzt von den Daten.
Nee, das ist ein sogenannter Spreizcode. Also da wird die Daten werden mit so einem, mit einer Folge von 1 und 0 multipliziert. Und damit wird das Signal auf einen Frequenzband gespreizt, nennt man das. Also ich habe dann eine Bandbreitenvergrößerung. Und im Empfänger verwende ich dann für jeden Satelliten den gleichen Code, führe diese Multiplikation und eine Aufsummierung dann wieder durch. Und dann kann ich, je nachdem welchen Code ich verwende, dann auf diese Nachrichten zugreifen.
Das heißt, das ist so eine Art Trick, dass mehrere Sender auf derselben Frequenz Daten senden können, ohne dass sie sich im einigen Sinne in die Quere kommen.
Ja, das ist ein sogenanntes CDMA-System. Code Division Multiple Access System.
Was ja auch so in der Computertechnologie weite Verwendung findet.
Also es gibt ja im Mobilfunk, haben wir hier glaube ich zurzeit einen TDMA, einen Time Division Multiple Access System. Dann gibt es Mischformen. Also man muss ja immer gucken, dass man die Bandbreite möglichst effizient nutzt, die ja beschränkt ist.
In dieser Botschaft, die jetzt die Satelliten aussenden, ist die Zeit in einer verdammt irre hohen Auflösung.
Ich synchronisiere mich dann praktisch mit dieser Zeit. Also da ist nur eine Korrektur und ich synchronisiere mich dann mit dem Zeitgeber auf dem Satelliten. Das mache ich mit meinem Empfänger.
Okay, was müsste jetzt dieser Empfänger oder was muss dieser Empfänger leisten? Ich bin auf meiner Nussschale irgendwo im Pazifik. Es gibt keinerlei Landmarken, an denen man sich irgendwie orientieren könnte. Dafür ist alles frei. Das heißt, ich dürfte, ja, wenn da 60, was hast du gesagt, 30, 28 Satelliten unterwegs sind.
Ich sehe maximal 10, 11 kann ich gleichzeitig sehen.
Ach echt, mehr nicht?
Nee, das wird nicht mehr.
Wenn sie doch eine ganze halbe Erde anstrahlen, also ein bisschen weniger als eine halbe Erde.
Ja, aber die sind dann sehr flach hinterm Horizont.
Achso, die müssen sozusagen auch gut im Blick sein. Ja, sie sollten gut im Blick sein. Okay, alles klar. Also 10 kann man maximal sehen.
Kommt aufs System drauf an.
Okay, das heißt auch so ein Pazifik, wo es auf einen Meter nicht ankommt, habe ich eigentlich die beste Navigation, ja?
Ja, ja, das ist eine schöne Umgebung.
Gut, so, das heißt jetzt schlagen 10 Signale auf mich ein. Ich kann ja dem Signal selbst keinerlei Richtung entnehmen.
Nein.
Das ist nicht möglich. Aber ich kann sie alle gleichzeitig empfangen, auf Basis dieses CDMA, und weiß auch, welches jetzt von welchem Satelliten ist. Und bei jedem ist sozusagen eine dreidimensionale Position. Ich bin da und da in dieser 25.000 km von der Erdoberfläche entfernten, gedachten Kugel entfernt. Und dann steht da eine Zeit drin. Und mehr nicht.
Mehr nicht.
Das war's. Und jetzt muss man, also das Gerät muss jetzt 4 oder 5 sich davon aussuchen?
Ja, der nimmt erstmal alle. Der nimmt erstmal alle so viele, wie er kann. Also der verarbeitet die Signale und macht eben dann seine Laufzeitmessung. Das heißt, am Ende hat er für jeden Satelliten den Abstand bestimmt. Da ist ganz wichtig zu sehen, dass wir hier eine Laufzeitbestimmung, eine Nanosekunde, sind ungefähr 30 cm. Das heißt, die Genauigkeit dieser Laufzeitmessung sollte also im Sub-, also im Nanosekunden...
Eine Nanosekunde sind 30 cm im Orbit.
Das geht über die Lichtgeschwindigkeit. Ich hoffe, ich mach jetzt hier keine Fehler.
Ich kann es jetzt nicht überprüfen. Ich glaub das mal so.
Und das heißt, der Empfänger muss schon einiges leisten, um das hinzukriegen. Das ist nicht so ganz einfach. Deshalb sind die Geräte auch so hochpräzise. Empfänger sind auch relativ teuer und kompliziert.
Ein Meter in drei Nanosekunden. Und dann rechnet man das alles zusammen, dann weiß man, wo man ist. Weil es kann sozusagen mathematisch nur noch einen einzigen Ort geben, an dem die Signale mit der entsprechenden Verzögerung eingetroffen sein können.
Alle zusammen eintreffen.
Darum geht es eigentlich. Man weiß, von wo aus sie abgeschickt wurden und wann. Und dann schaut man sich eigentlich nur noch an, wie lange haben sie jetzt zu mir gebraucht. Und nur der Laufzeit, ich meine, die Dinger sind ja mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit unterwegs, das ist ja nicht besonders langsam. Aber das reicht sozusagen. Also auch über 25.000 Kilometer kann man dem schon eine Latenz entnehmen. Und das macht einen riesen Unterschied aus, ob der Satellit bei mir drüber, direkt über mir ist oder ob er schon so auf dem Wege zum Horizont ist. Das ist ganz schön pfiffig.
Ja, so ein kompliziertes System. Und man sieht auch, dass dieses Bodensystem sehr viel leisten muss und der Satellit auch. Also alle Involvierten müssen hochgenau arbeiten.
Also wie viele Bodensysteme sind dann permanent so in Kontakt mit den Satelliten?
Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich glaube Galileo wird fast bis zu 40 Bodenstationen haben. Wobei, da muss man unterscheiden, da gibt es Stationen, die nur beobachten, Stationen, die mit den Satelliten in Kontakt stehen. Da kenne ich aber leider jetzt nicht genau die Anzahl. Aber die sind meistens am Äquator verteilt, also um den Äquator, um die ganze Erde. Also da hat man auch an entlegenen Orten auf irgendwelchen schönen Inseln irgendwelche sogenannte Ablinkstationen. Und damit man eben permanent mit den Satelliten in Verbindung bleiben kann. Aber es sind schon eine ganze Menge. Also für Galileo sind glaube ich 40 geplant. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie jetzt alle 40 in der ersten ausbrauchen.
Bei GBS ist es ähnlich?
Ähnliche, ähnliche Anzahl. Die haben sogar teilweise die gleichen Orte.
Wie viele dürften davon so gleichzeitig kaputtgehen, dass es noch funktioniert?
Das System alleine glaube ich kann bis zu 24, über 24 Stunden autark arbeiten, sodass es immer noch sehr genau ist. Also es verliert dann über die Zeit an Genauigkeit, weil eben diese, die Satellitenpositionen nicht mehr so genau bekannt sind, die Uhren in den Satelliten langsam anfangen zu driften, weil sie nicht mehr durch diese Referenzzeit am Boden, die sehr sehr hoch genau ist, abgedatet werden. Also es geht sicher noch einige Zeit. Die Amerikaner haben das schon so designt, dass im Fall des Falles, dass sie da noch einige Zeit, also ich weiß 24 Stunden ist anscheinend kein Thema.
Also nach 24 Stunden kein Bodenstationkontakt, würde man quasi immer noch sein Autonavi würde irgendwie funktionieren.
Ja, man könnte noch gut rumfahren.
Aber wenn das jetzt so eine Woche so weitergeht, dann ist man irgendwie in der falschen Straße und irgendwann fangen Dinge an, in andere Dinge hinein zu fahren vermutlich. Naja, ich meine, das sind ja auch durchaus so Assessments, die man mal machen muss bei der Planung, oder? Solche Notfalls.
Ja, das ist wichtig, weil es gibt drei Hauptstationen, glaube ich, bei den Amerikanern, also zwei Hauptkontrollpunkte und dann eben diese ganzen Bodenstationen. Da ist sehr wahrscheinlich, dass da ab und zu die Bodenstationen ausfallen, irgendwas repariert werden muss. Da wird zwar alles gedoppelt, oder dreifach, also die haben dann teilweise dreifach die Sendeanlage zum Satelliten, damit wenn eine ausfällt, dann die anderen zwei funktionieren noch. Also da wird sehr hoch redundant gearbeitet.
Aber wie machen die das, dass diese ganzen Bodenstationen dieselbe Zeit haben?
Die synchronisieren sich dann wieder über das System.
Ach, die synchronisieren sich über diese Satelliten?
Ja, und auch über ein Bodensystem, soweit ich das weiß. Oder die haben selber auch noch Uhren, die nicht so schnell driften.
Was sind das für Uhren? So Atomuhren?
Ja, ja, es sind alles Atomuhren.
Alles Atomuhren. Verstehe, das ist also ein permanentes Korrektiv. Es gibt im Wesentlichen eigentlich nur eine wirkliche Masterzeit, die an einem Ort vorgehalten wird. Und so man eine Verbindung auf dem Landwege hat, wird die vielleicht genutzt. Ansonsten korrigiert man eben diese Zeiten auch da drüber. Das ist ein bisschen absurd, dass die Satelliten, die eigentlich von der Bodenstation gesagt bekommen sollen, wie spät es ist, dann auch der Bodenstationen sagen, wie spät es ist. Das ist ja sozusagen die Konsequenz dabei, oder? Aber so ist es. Es ist sozusagen ein mathematischer Kampf um die richtige Zeit.
Ja, die Übertragung von dieser Referenzzeit ist irre schwierig. Ich kann das nicht einfach über ein Kabel irgendwo hin übertragen.
Weil auch da Laufzeiten...
Ich muss versuchen, Uhren zu haben an meinen Standorten, die nicht so schnell abweichen von dieser, wenn sie einmal synchronisiert worden sind. Und dann habe ich eben für diese kurze Zeitspanne, bin ich dann synchronisiert und dann kann ich diese Messungen machen.
So, das war jetzt sozusagen die ideale Welt. Du hast ja vorhin schon begonnen, ein bisschen zu schildern, was da sozusagen alles noch dazwischen kommen kann. Also jetzt, wo man sich sozusagen mal klarmacht, wie es eigentlich idealerweise funktionieren müsste, ist die Frage, ja, okay, jetzt regnet's oder was weiß ich. Da ist dann sozusagen auch richtig Gewitter und dementsprechend viel elektromagnetisches Feuer unterwegs. Wie beeinflusst das diese Signale? Was ist das für ein Frequenzbereich?
Das ist das sogenannte L-Band, also ungefähr um die 1,2, 1,5 Gigahertz. Warum das? Das hat man so gewählt, damit gerade die Effekte in der sogenannten Troposphäre sehr stark abhängig von dem Frequenzband sind. Also je die Abhängigkeit, je höher die Frequenz wird, desto stärker wird zum Beispiel meine Dämpfung bei Regen. Und deshalb hat man diese Frequenzbänder auch gewählt, weil die einen guten Kompromiss bieten zu diesen verschiedenen Ausbreitungs-Effekten.
Was würde jetzt passieren, wenn man noch eine höhere Frequenz nimmt?
Dann habe ich eine stärkere Dämpfung, also weniger Leistung meines Signals an meinem Empfänger.
Und wenn ich weiter runter gehe?
Dann wird es besser. Aber es gibt andere Effekte, die dann schlechter werden. Da müsste ich meine Kollegen genau fragen, die in der Ionosphäre tätig sind, wie das sich da verhält.
Das heißt, die Atmosphärenschichten haben sozusagen unterschiedliche Absorptionsverhalten.
Die prägen bestimmte Effekte aufs Signal auf und die sind frequenzabhängig. Man hat eben diese Frequenzbänder gewählt, damit man verschiedene Effekte nicht zu stark ausgeprägt sind. Die muss man halt irgendwie versuchen, alle unter einen Hut zu kriegen.
Troposphäre ist ja sozusagen die Unterste der Erdatmosphären. Also Troposphäre, Stratosphäre, Meso, Thermo, da gibt es eine ganze Menge Sphären. Die haben alle unterschiedliches Verhalten oder ist das im Wesentlichen so dasselbe Verhalten, bloß dann eben unterschiedlich intensiv? Oder ist eigentlich nur die Troposphäre ein Problem?
Also die Troposphäre ist eigentlich das kleinste Problem, weil da hat man relativ gute Modelle und kann das relativ gut vorhersagen. Schwierig ist die sogenannte Ionosphäre. Da sind nämlich so Elektronen, Wolken unterwegs und in verschiedener Dichte und die bewegen sich. Und die müsste man, muss man eigentlich permanent beobachten, um wirklich zu wissen, wie die Ausbreitungskarakteristiken des Signals dann sind. Und die sind aber zum Glück auch frequenzabhängig. Das heißt, wenn ich zwei Frequenzen betrachte, kann ich diese Effekte korrigieren.
Also man rechnet sozusagen die Atmosphäre gleich mit raus.
Man kann sie korrigieren im Empfänger. Wenn ich mehrere Frequenzen gleichzeitig betrachte, kann ich sie im Empfänger korrigieren.
Das heißt, eigentlich kann man sagen, die ganze Intelligenz des Systems, also die wesentliche Intelligenz des Systems, steckt eigentlich im Empfänger.
Ja, der muss sehr, sehr viel Arbeit leisten.
Das war, ich meine, Satelliten-Engineering, das hat natürlich seine eigenen Herausforderungen. Aber es ist sozusagen auch bei Design so gemacht worden, dass man dann eben die Optimierung auch im Gerät machen kann. Das heißt, die Infrastruktur bleibt gleich über einen langen, langen Zeitraum. Fliegen ja jetzt schon ein paar Jahrzehnte die Dinger. Und im Wesentlichen hat sich da kaum was geändert. Und auf dem Boden kann man dann quasi den Fortschritt machen, indem man das einfach immer besser ausgewertet bekommt und besser gefiltert bekommt. Was ist denn der Grund? Ich meine, wenn ich so einen Teil jetzt einschalte, so einen GPS-Empfänger, dann dauert das ja erst mal richtig lange.
Das dauert deshalb sehr lange, weil der sich erst mal diese ganzen Satellitenpositionen, den sogenannten Almanach, runterlädt, wenn er total lange aus war. Das nennt man den sogenannten Cold Start. Das kann bei GPS bis zu 12 Minuten dauern, bis er wirklich alles heruntergeladen hat. Das Problem ist, dass GPS eine unglaublich langsame Daten oder niedrige Datenrate hat. Die haben 50 Hertz. Das heißt also 50 Bit pro Sekunde werden da oder 50 Symbole pro Sekunde werden übertragen. Das ist irre irre langsam. Und wenn man da an so Verbindungsgeschwindigkeiten im WLAN denkt, zu Hause hat da jeder seine, weiß nicht wie viele Kilobit und das ist irre irre langsam. Und deshalb dauert das so lang.
Aber was lädt er sich denn runter? Er muss von jedem Satelliten, das gibt ja sonst eigentlich nichts. Aber er braucht doch nur vier.
Ja, aber er weiß erstmal nicht wo er ist. Er weiß nicht, welche brauche ich denn. Was er erstmal macht, ist er sucht erstmal, welche Satelliten sehe ich denn. Da fängt er an zu suchen, das ist so die Akquisition. Da versucht er herzustellen, den Kontakt mit dem Satelliten herzustellen. Kontakt ist übertrieben, weil er empfängt nichts zurück zu senden. Er versucht einfach nur mal festzustellen, welche sehe ich denn.
Aber die müsste er doch eigentlich ziemlich schnell sehen, weil die doch alle die ganze Zeit senden oder nicht?
Ja, die senden die ganze Zeit, aber es dauert eine Zeit lang, bis er sicher ist, welche Satelliten er sieht.
Also, dass er sich sicher ist, dass das, was er da empfängt, auch wirklich empfangen hat. Aber gibt es da nicht so Prüf-Summen etc., mit denen man das schnell überprüfen kann?
Ja, da gibt es verschiedene Prüf-Summen. Und dann kommt es natürlich auch darauf an, in welcher Umgebung ich mich befinde. Also, wenn ich mich in einer etwas schwierigen Umgebung befinde, wo die Leistung der empfangenen Satelliten nicht besonders hoch ist, wo ich vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen irgendwie gestört bin, dann kann das noch länger dauern.
Wie viele Daten sind denn jetzt in so einer Botschaft drin? Also, ich meine, wie viele Sekunden dauert das wirklich, bis ich jetzt einmal eine Positionsmeldung eines Satelliten bekommen habe? Dauert das jetzt eine Minute oder dauert das irgendwie ein paar Sekunden? Im Minutenbereich. Das heißt, obwohl die so schnell unterwegs sind und einem irgendwie alles eine Nanosekundenauflösung liefern, brauchen sie einfach verdammt lange, um einem irgendwie erst mal was zu erzählen. Und warum ist die Datenrate so niedrig?
Das hat damit zu tun, dass ich diese hochauflösende Laufzeitmessung auch machen möchte gleichzeitig. Und deshalb kann ich die Datenrate nicht beliebig hoch machen und gleichzeitig aber auch sicherstellen, dass ich eben diese Laufzeitmessung im Nanosekundenbereich durchführen kann. Das schließt sich leider ein bisschen aus. Man kann da was optimieren. Das ist sicher, es ist sehr schlecht, was GPS uns da liefert. Galileo wird da mehr liefern. Und zwar um Faktor 5 teilweise, Faktor 10 sogar. Aber da gibt es Grenzen. Also wenn ich weiterhin diese hohe Laufzeitauflösung machen möchte, mit dieser Qualität auch, dann kann ich die Datenrate nicht beliebig hoch machen.
Ja, aber was würde denn dann passieren, wenn ich jetzt einfach dieselbe in mich bin? Das ist doch nur die reine Information. Ich bin jetzt hier und die Uhrzeit ist...
Da ist noch mehr.
Da gibt es noch ein geheimes...
Nein, da gibt es nichts geheimes. Es werden noch mehr Korrekturdaten übertragen. Die Message muss auch noch synchronisiert werden und richtig detektiert werden.
Also erstmal was senden, um zu sagen, jetzt geht es los. So Startsequenzen, Endsequenzen. Hier hat es angefangen, hier ist es zu Ende. Was für Korrekturen werden da noch gesendet?
Für die Uhren werden, glaube ich, Korrekturdaten gesendet.
Ach so, klar, damit die Bodenstationen sich da auch entsprechend wiederum auf die Zeit...
Ja, weil die Uhren im Satelliten sind auf die Bodensegmentzeit synchronisiert. Weichen aber davon haben einen gewissen Drift und da wird eine Korrektur übertragen.
Okay, alles klar. Also wir stellen fest, Navigationssatellit sein, zumindest im GPS-System, ist ein mühsames Geschäft. Da gehen die Daten dann halt doch sehr langsam und sehr koordiniert raus, weil sonst würde das gar nicht anders funktionieren. Und es gibt eine ganze Menge auch mitzuteilen. Und deswegen muss der Empfänger, wenn er in diesen Kaltstatemodus kommt, überhaupt erstmal von jedem Satelliten den richtigen Moment finden, wo denn eine Nachricht überhaupt erstmal anfängt. Und dann muss sie auch fertig empfangen werden. Und das kann für jeden halt dann irgendwie 1, 2, 3 Minuten dauern, je nachdem, wie gut die Empfangsverhältnisse tatsächlich sind und wo man ihn jetzt in dem Moment auch gerade erfischt hat. Aber jetzt sagen wir mal, im günstigsten Fall, tolles Wetter, Ionosphäre, hat Urlaub. Und ich bin auf dem Pazifik und ich sehe irgendwie ganz viele Satelliten. Da ist es dann schon realistisch, dass man sich auch so in 2, 3 Minuten dann irgendwie eingefangen hat auf alles.
Ja, ich glaube es im Bereich von 5 bis 10 Minuten ist irgendwo gut.
Und was meint es so vorhin mit diesem ALMA nach?
Ja, das ist das sogenannte, wie so ein Buch, wo diese ganzen Satellitenpositionen übertragen werden. Damit er weiß, wo er, damit er diese ganzen Positionen übertragen bekommt. Und wichtig ist vielleicht auch zu bedenken bei der ganzen Sache, ist, dass die Satelliten ja nur eine endliche Leistung haben, die sie abstrahlen können. Also die sind nur endlich groß. Die Solar-Panels können nur bestimmte elektrische Energie erzeugen. Und wir haben hier nicht, wie bei einem terrestrischen System, da gibt es nicht so einen Knopf, wir wollen jetzt einfach stärker abstrahlen, dann drehen wir halt mal auf. Die Signale sind tief unterm Rauschen, wenn wir sie, wenn man sie empfangen oder der Empfänger sie empfängt. Und deshalb dauert das auch so lang. Also die Datenrate kann auch nicht beliebig erhöht werden, weil eben die Signalleistung sehr, sehr schlecht ist. Und sonst würden die Fehlerraten der Datenerkennung steigen, sonst extrem an. Also da hat man noch so ein Problem, dass man eben nicht, ich kann nicht dem Satelliten sagen, hey man, ich hör dich schlecht, sprich mal lauter. Das geht nicht.
Weil der flüstert sozusagen eigentlich immer mit der konstanten Geschwindigkeit.
Weil der brüllt eh schon, der brüllt eh schon von seiner Position auf die Erde und hat nicht mehr sehr viel Spielraum, da noch lauter zu brüllen.
Die laufen auch nur auf Solarpower.
Sie haben Treibstoff natürlich, um die Position zu klären. Soweit ich weiß. Also sie haben da keine zusätzlichen, die haben natürlich Batterien, um die Energie zwischenzuspeichern, denke ich. Aber da ist kein Atomkraftwerk an Bord oder sowas.
So, das heißt, wenn ich so ein Almanach empfangen habe, das heißt, ich weiß, was gerade so fliegt. Und ich weiß auch, was quasi für mich so wichtig ist. Aber das ändert sich ja auch laufend. Es kommt ja immer wieder ein neuer dazu. Aber weiß man dann sozusagen schon, wenn ich sozusagen die 10, die ich jetzt maximal sehen kann, gesehen und verortet habe, dann weiß ich auch, wo die lang fliegen. Da müsste ich ja im Prinzip auch schon wissen, wer als Nächste über den Horizont kommt.
Jaja, das ist dann, wenn der Empfänger dann in diesem, wenn er sich einmal lokalisiert hat, dann ist er relativ gut, weil dann kann er ziemlich viel vorhersagen. Ich meine, das wiederholt, also was er sieht, wenn der Empfänger stehen bleibt und man nur die Satelliten über einen Tag, also bei GPS sind es 24 Stunden, dann wiederholt sich das wieder. Da sieht er eigentlich das gleiche noch mal. Wenn er mal läuft, dann ist er sehr gut. Das Problem ist, das wird jeder schon mal gesehen haben, wenn man aus der Tiefgarage sein Auto startet, seinen Navigationsempfänger anmacht, da jetzt klug die Adresse schon eingegeben hat, und dann meint, wenn man dann rausfährt, dass man dann sofort los navigieren kann, dem ist leider nicht so. Da braucht man dann, um das sofort zu können, da wären wir dann bei dem Assisted GPS, wo ich über einen Kommunikationslink mit wesentlich höherer Datenrate diesen Almanach übertragen bekomme und verschiedene andere Zusatzinformationen. Und damit ist der Empfänger schneller bereit, zu wissen, welche Satelliten gibt es, nach welchen muss ich eigentlich suchen. Damit wird er viel, viel schneller. Er kann eben diese, was man nennt, Time to First Fix, kann er wesentlich verkürzen.
Aber dieser Eimernach ist ja sozusagen immer auch positionsrelativ. Also das ist sozusagen ein Informationsblatt.
Nee, nee, das ist eine Position in einem, die Erde umspannend, oder die Erde ist glaube ich im Mittelpunkt dieses Koordinatensystems. Und damit ist es überall auf der Erde gleich. Ich befinde mich auch irgendwo in diesem Koordinatensystem. Und deshalb ist es immer die gleiche Information.
Das heißt, wenn ich einen GPS-Empfänger habe, der, sagen wir mal parallel, also in Telefonen ist das natürlich jetzt, iPhone etc. Die ganzen normalen Smartphones, die haben natürlich ohnehin schon Internetverbindungen bzw. Verbindungen zu ihren GSM-Providern, die das ja auch mit anbieten. Und da kann dann quasi über so eine separate Datenanfrage gesagt werden, hier, hör mal, ich habe hier GPS, aber ich habe gerade keinen Plan, schick mal einmal nach. Und dann kriegt er sozusagen den aktuellen Zustand des Systems, welcher Satellitgrad wo lang fliegt. Und kriegt man dann sozusagen mit diesem einmal nach auch schon so in etwa eine Vorstellung, wo man dann ist.
Beim Assistenten GPS natürlich, weil wenn ich an meinem Telefon habe, dann weiß der Provider, in welchem Zelle mich da gerade aufhalte und der kann dann schon mal ganz grob, und in der Stadt sind diese Zellen sehr, sehr klein, deshalb funktioniert es in Städten sehr, sehr gut. Dann weiß der schon ungefähr, also da wird es dann immer besser die Information. Der weiß dann, ah, du solltest eigentlich die fünf Satelliten sehen und nach den anderen brauchst du jetzt gar nicht suchen.
Dieser Einmach ist ja auch nicht besonders groß. Ich meine, wir reden ja nicht von vielen Daten. Für jeden den, ja, einmal so eine Nachricht, quasi wie man sie empfangen würde, bloß über den Satellitenweg dauert es halt eine Minute und so sind es aber dann auch nur ein paar Bites. Das heißt, so ein kleines Datenpaket hilft dem Gerät schon weiter, um dann eben auch sofort zu sagen, ok, alles klar, jetzt sehe ich den, den und den. Das passt so jetzt hier gerade in mein aktuelles Weltbild hinein und jetzt kann ich exakt daraus berechnen. Wie genau kann GPS denn sein?
Also GPS in einer schönen Umgebung, das heißt, so wie wir uns auf dem freien Feld irgendwo befinden, kann es extrem genau sein. Also ich kann in den Metabereich kommen, ohne zusätzliche Hilfen. Wenn wir zusätzliche Hilfen einschalten, wie zum Beispiel Differential GPS, da bekomme ich von einer zusätzlichen Bodenstation, die hauptsächlich den Fehler in der Ionosphäre bestimmt, eine zusätzliche Nachricht geschickt, wieder über einen Kommunikationskanal, die mir den aktuellen Fehler, den ich auch sehen sollte, mitteilt. Und dann kann ich eine Korrektur vornehmen in meinem Empfänger, die diese Laufzeitunterschiede, die durch die Ionosphäre eingestreut werden, kann ich korrigieren und damit kann ich sehr, sehr genau werden.
Das heißt dieser Fehler der Ionosphäre ist sozusagen so ein Bremswert?
Ja, der ist einer der dominanten Fehler, würde ich sagen. Und zwar ist es ein Fehler, der über eine größere Fläche sozusagen in der Regel konstant ist. Das heißt, viele, viele Empfänger sehen diesen gleichen Fehler und deshalb macht es Sinn, über solche Referenzstationen den Fehler zu bestimmen und dann an alle Empfänger in der Umgebung zu verteilen.
Das heißt, so wie man sozusagen seine Zeit korrigieren kann, kann man auch sehen, alles klar, mehrere Geräte stellen jetzt so eine Verzögerung fest, die eigentlich gar nicht sein kann. Alles wieder komplexe mathematische Zeitmodelle, die an der Stelle zum Tragen kommen. Und dann wird das sozusagen als die aktuelle Wetterstandsbericht, Ionosphäre, Wetterbericht sozusagen.
Ja, das wird in guten Zeiten so angenommen. Da gibt es natürlich auch Probleme, weil die Ionosphäre sich lokal auch sehr stark ändern kann in Extremsituationen. Also wenn die Sonnenaktivität steigt, dann fängt auch unsere Ionosphäre an sich, weil da fallen von der Sonne sehr viel Material auf die Erde ein, fängt die Ionosphäre an, sich auch darauf zu reagieren. Und das kann so ein bisschen unruhig auch werden. Aber in der Regel ist es ein Effekt, der eher großflächig gleich ist. Und dann gibt es eben Effekte, die lokal nur jeder Einzelne sehen. Also diese Mehrwege-Ausbreitungen und teilweise auch Interferenzen, also Störungen durch andere Geräte oder durch andere Systeme. Die sieht eventuell jeder nur punktuell in seinem eigenen Empfänger. Und da muss der Empfänger durch geschickte Signalverarbeitung, die kann ich nicht mehr durch irgendwelche Korrekturen korrigieren, die muss wirklich der Empfänger dann selbst korrigieren.
Wenn jetzt so was wie Sonnenwind da ein echtes Problem ist, heißt das, dass dann GPS so am Pol generell schlechter funktioniert? Dadurch, dass das Magnetfeld da irgendwie den ganzen Sonnenwind einfängt und damit Aurora, Borealis, allerlei Himmelszauber veranstaltet, kann ich mir ja vorstellen, dass da richtig Panik ist.
Also ich weiß, dass am Äquator die Ionosphärenaktivität viel stärker ist. Okay, also der Pol scheint nicht so das Problem zu sein. Aber wahrscheinlich, ich sag sicher wieder was Falsches, am Pol wird es...
Und das in einem Podcast. Ja, okay, also es ist einfach sozusagen etwas, was sich permanent ändert, aber das System misst es, die ganzen Bodenstationen, sonstige Referenzempfänger, die vielleicht noch irgendwo installiert sind, nehmen diese Information mit auf. Und das wird dann quasi exklusiv an diese speziellen Referenzpunkte für das differenzielle GPS hin übermittelt. Sind das private Stationen oder ist es so, dass wenn ich jetzt einen entsprechenden Empfänger habe, dass ich alle möglichen Referenzpunkte automatisch auch mit nutzen kann?
Nee, nee, das sind normalerweise Stationen, die für bestimmte Services aufgebaut werden und betrieben werden und da wird in der Regel kann man die nicht mit jedem Empfänger empfangen.
Was sind das für Services?
Also es gibt, an einer Sache wird sehr, sehr viel gearbeitet. Man möchte eben dieses differenzielle GPS verwenden, um Flugzeuge zu landen und dann ist man bei einem sogenannten Ground-Based Augmentation System. Da sollen an Flughäfen solche Referenzstationen aufgebaut werden, die eben genau diese jonospherischen Fehler bestimmen und viele, viele andere Dinge noch machen. Und diese Informationen werden dann an die Empfänger in den Flugzeugen übertragen und die Flugzeuge, die sich in der gleichen Umgebung wie diese Referenzstation befinden, können dann eben den jonospherischen Fehler korrigieren.
Also ist das jetzt so für komplizierte Flughäfen in irgendwelchen engen Tälern?
Nein, das wollen sie für alle. Man hat ja an allen Flughäfen zurzeit verschiedene Systeme, damit der Pilot auch bei schlecht Wetter, bei schlechter Sicht weiß, wo er hinzufliegen hat. Das möchte man in Zukunft ersetzen, weil diese Systeme schwierig sind, teilweise nicht so genau sind, teilweise schwierig zu warten sind, teuer sind. Ich brauch für jede Landebahn, für jede Richtung so ein System, zum Beispiel, zur Zeit. In Zukunft möchte man dann nur noch eine Referenzstation haben, und das basiert auf diesem Prinzip des Differential GPS weitgehend, die dann diese Korrekturdaten an die Flugzeuge schickt.
Und das geht dann auch sozusagen über denselben Frequenzkanal?
Nein, da gibt es spezielle Frequenzbänder, in denen dann diese Informationen an die Empfänger übertragen werden, an den Flugzeugen.
Okay, also das ist eine exklusive Geschichte mit dem D-GPS. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man sagen kann, ach naja, jetzt hier für Bereiche wie Städte etc., wo man es halt auch mal ein bisschen genauer haben möchte, bauen wir einfach nochmal neben die GSM-Antenne auch nochmal so einen Differenzsender dazu und dann wird alles besser. So ist es nicht.
So ist es nicht, aber es gibt einen Differenzsender im Weltall. Also es gibt ein sogenanntes EGNOS-System, das ist das European Geostationary Navigation Overlay System. Da gibt es mehrere geostationäre Satelliten, die diese Aufgabe übernehmen und die übermitteln sozusagen eine Ionosphärenfehlerkarte für ganz Europa. Und da gibt es wieder ein Bodennetz und da gibt es eben haufenweise Referenzstationen am Boden für dieses EGNOS-System, die eben diese ionosphärischen Aktivitäten und andere Dinge messen. Und die Informationen werden gesammelt in einem zentralen Einrichtung und dort in einem Message gepackt zu einem geostationären Satelliten transferiert. Und der strahlt die über ganz Europa ab. Da gibt es mehrere, ich glaube zwei oder drei EGNOS-Satelliten. Zurzeit glaube ich, sind es zwei. Und die machen das auf dem gleichen Frequenzband wie GPS. Das heißt, jeder GPS-Empfänger, der EGNOS, der muss EGNOS verarbeiten können, das ist aber keine große Kunst, weil das die gleichen Signale sind und die gleiche Technik kann verwendet werden, der kann über EGNOS seine ionosphärischen Korrekturen bekommen.
Das ist aber noch eine relativ neue Geschichte.
EGNOS ist schon operationabel oder operationell. 2009 ist ganz neu.
Und ab jetzt muss jeder neue GPS-Empfänger das auch können?
Es ist sicher gut, dass er es kann. Es muss nicht jeder können, aber es ist eine Möglichkeit.
Also wenn er es kann, also es gibt jetzt keine Vorschrift, was ein GPS-Chip können muss, etc. Sondern gibt es schon welche, die es können?
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Also das heißt, wenn ich jetzt mir ein GPS-Gerät kaufe und da steht drauf Yes, Adjoints with Agnos, dann habe ich sozusagen mein Weltall-Differenz-GPS mit drin, weil ich einfach direkt von dem geostationären Satelliten in dem Fall keine Position und Zeit gesendet bekomme, weil die ist quasi implizit, sondern ich kriege sozusagen nur so einen. Übrigens, die Eonosphere ist gerade so und so schlecht.
Man kann auch zusätzliche Daten übertragen, aber das ist die Hauptkomponente ist diese.
Also das ist so ein ESA-Projekt. Und arbeitet aber quasi allen anderen Navigationssystemen zu.
Ja, also zurzeit unterstützt es halt GPS, weil das ist für uns das operationelle System zurzeit. Soll aber auch in Zukunft dann auch Galileo unterstützen.
Und Wetter? Ist Wetter auch ein Problem? Regen hast du vorhin gesagt, aber ich weiß jetzt nicht, wiefern das was ausmacht. Also irgendwie muss man sich da Sorgen machen.
Ja, nicht so. Also Regen kann natürlich die Signalleistung beeinflussen, aber da gibt es wie gesagt im Empfänger ganz gute Modelle, um das zu, eine Korrektur vorzunehmen. Das wird meistens im Empfänger korrigiert, die Einflüsse, die durch die Troposphäre entstehen.
Wie viel Luft ist denn noch in diesem GPS? Ich meine, wenn das so ein System ist, was sich durch die Verbesserung der Empfänger auch verbessert, wie zum Beispiel AgNOS auch noch miterkennen, beziehungsweise einfach leistungsfähigere Chips, die noch besser in der Lage sind, das eigentliche Signal herauszufiltern, von daher vielleicht nicht mehr so lange brauchen, um sich zu synchronisieren, den ALMA nachher runterzuladen etc. Ist da jetzt schon alles rausgeholt, was man aus GPS noch so rausholen kann?
Nee, nee, die Amerikaner sind ja dabei, ihr System zu modernisieren. Also sie haben ja neue Signale definiert. Sie werden zusätzlich auch noch eine, und zwar zivile Signale, definiert. Das ist sehr, sehr wichtig, dazu zu sagen. Sie haben eine neue Frequenz auch dazu genommen, das sogenannte L5-Band. Vorher hatten sie nur zwei Frequenzen belegt und jetzt sind es eben drei. Wobei, da gibt es erst einen Satelliten, der da Signale darauf abstrahlt. Die brauchen natürlich ein bisschen länger, um ihre Satelliten zu modernisieren, weil die wollen natürlich nicht alle wegschmeißen und sagen, wir schießen jetzt hier ganz neue Satelliten, sondern die sind dabei so nach und nach, ihr System zu verbessern.
Also jeder Satellit, der jetzt quasi end of life ist?
Ja, der hat neue Features an Bord.
Und wie häufig kommt da ein neuer hoch?
Ich glaube, dieses Jahr haben sie einen geschossen und sie haben da einen Plan, da kann man nachschauen, wann sie da Sachen planen.
Das ist schon mehr als einer pro Jahr, sonst würde es ja noch mal vier Jahrzehnte dauern.
Ja, die haben da einen Plan, ich glaube, die wollen in den nächsten vier, fünf Jahren da ihre Konstellation erneuern.
Und dann hat man sozusagen GPS 2.0?
So eine Art, genau. Da wird Stück für Stück werden halt immer mehr Satelliten mit den neuen Features gestartet.
Und dann ist es noch genauer?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also man muss bedenken, GPS ist immer ein bisschen, finde ich immer ein bisschen unfair, GPS zu vergleichen. Aber das jetzige System, weil man muss überlegen, wir arbeiten mit einem Signal, das niemals dafür entwickelt worden ist, von privaten Nutzern verarbeitet zu werden, auch noch für diesen Zweck. Wir arbeiten mit einem militärischen Hilfsignal. Dieses Signal ist nur dafür eigentlich da gewesen, um dem militärischen Empfänger es zu ermöglichen, eine Positionsberechnung zu starten, das zu erleichtern. Damit arbeiten wir mit diesem Hilfsobjekt.
Die Ergebnisse sind eigentlich ganz ordentlich.
Ja, sie sind sehr ordentlich dafür. Deshalb finde ich es ab und zu ein bisschen schwierig, GPS mit neu entwickelten Systemen, wie zum Beispiel Galileo, zu vergleichen. Galileo hat einen ganz anderen Anspruch. Die haben hauptsächlich zivile Nutzer im Auge. Sie haben dann einfach auch viel mehr Zeit gehabt, von den GPS-Entwicklungen zu lernen. Und die Amerikaner, man muss jetzt ein bisschen noch warten, bis alle Satelliten diese neuen Features haben. Und dann denke ich, der Endnutzer sollte vielleicht einfach noch ein bisschen warten, um sein Urteil zu fällen.
Ja, ich wollte ja jetzt gar nicht über ein GPS-Herz reden, sondern die immer im Raum stehende Frage ist natürlich auch, naja, jetzt werden wir GPS haben, dann ist ja alles super. Wozu brauchen wir denn dann überhaupt noch was anderes? Aber es ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass es nicht auch andere Systeme bereits gäbe. Also es gibt GLONASS, das System der Russen, das ist ja auch schon eine Weile in Betrieb. Ich weiß nicht, wann haben die damit angefangen?
Ja, ich glaube, es war ungefähr gleich mit den Amerikanern.
Und Galileo gibt es in dem Sinne noch nicht, da werden wir gleich noch ein bisschen ausführlicher drauf kommen. Gibt es sonst noch was, was schon in Betrieb ist?
Es gibt einige Kompass-Satelliten. Das ist ein chinesisches System, das sich im Aufbau befindet. Es gibt, glaube ich, auch schon einen japanischen Satelliten. Die haben so eine Art Hilfssystem für GPS betreiben, die auch. Das ist aber kein globales System, sondern ein lokales System. Die Satelliten sind nur lokal über Japan und in Umgebung sichtbar.
Ein JPS, ein japanisches Positionierungssystem.
Ja, so was Ähnliches. Und dann gibt es noch die INDA-Planen, auch noch ein lokales System aufzubauen, was auch GPS unterstützt. Das ist auch ein Grund, denke ich, oder fast der wichtigste Grund, warum Europa auch ein eigenes System haben möchte. Wir wollen nicht abhängig sein von den Entscheidungen des Departments of Defense. Wenn ich heute meine Firma oder meinen Service, den ich anbieten will, basierend auf Satellitennavigation mache, in Europa, dann möchte ich eventuell nicht von den Entscheidungen des Departments auf Defense abhängig sein, wann sie denn jetzt neue Satelliten schießen und wann sie das System anschalten, ausschalten. Die können beliebig da agieren. Mit dem System Galileo habe ich immerhin die Beruhigung, sage ich mal, oder die Ruhe, dass ich da einen politischen Verantwortlichen greifbar vor Ort habe, dem ich sagen kann, hey, ich habe hier meinen Business Case auf diesem System aufgebaut. Ihr habt mir eigentlich zugesagt, dass dieser Service funktioniert, und jetzt geht es nicht.
Das heißt, die eigentliche Entdeckung ist, Navigationssysteme, Satellitennavigationssysteme sind einfach eine tolle Sache, nicht nur um Panzer, um durch die Gegend zu navigieren, sondern damit kann man ganz viele andere Sachen machen. Wir haben ja auch schon so einiges aufgezählt, und das kennt ja eigentlich auch jeder. Autonavigation, Flugzeugnavigation, Schiffnavigation. Aber in Zeiten des mehr oder weniger universell vorhandenen Internets überall, zumindest so in den Ballungsräumen, Location-based Services, das Ganze spielt sich ja immer weiter. Da gibt es einfach einen riesigen Hunger nach wirklich genauer Positionierung. Wie sind denn jetzt die Europäer an dieses Projekt Galileo herangegangen? Unter diesem ganzen Vorzeichen, man weiß schon, man hat schon viel Erfahrung gesammelt. Es gibt sozusagen neue Anwendungen am Horizont. Welches Ziel wurde denn gesteckt, außer, dass man jetzt was eigenes haben will. Und wir bauen jetzt nochmal dasselbe nach. Hätte man ja auch machen können, dass man einfach seinen GPS-Klon ins Weltall klebt und dann macht es einfach genau das gleiche.
Also man wollte noch, das ist ein wichtiger Punkt denke ich, man wollte dem Nutzer auch, das wird auch über diese Navigationsnachricht mitgeteilt an im Fall von Galileo, man wollte dem Nutzer eine Integritätsinformation zukommen lassen. Das heißt, funktioniert das System gerade so wie es soll oder nicht? Das stellt nämlich GPS dem Nutzer nicht bereit. Und da gab es Fälle in der Vergangenheit, da haben drei Monate lang ein Satellit eine Message geschickt, die unvollständig war oder falsch war. Und das hat natürlich keiner gemerkt. Aber die Amerikaner geben da keine Informationen darüber. Diese Informationen, und deshalb ist es auch eine Aufgabe dieser Differential GPS-Stationen, die man verwenden möchte, um Flugzeuge, also an einem G-Bus-System zu navigieren. Die müssen z.B. auch die Signalqualität-Monitoren sagen, ja, das Signal hat die Qualität so, dass wir auch wirklich ordentlich navigieren können und viele, viele andere Qualitätsmerkmale überprüfen, bevor ich diesen Service benutzen darf oder kann, oder zufällig benutzen kann, mit Zuverlässigkeit benutzen kann. Und Galileo wird viele dieser Informationen dem Nutzer über das System mitteilen. Und das wird praktisch durch diese Bodenstationen die Qualität des Services überprüft. Und der Nutzer kriegt eine Art Integritätsnachricht, das heißt, ja, es ist alles super oder nicht. Und das heißt, man kann sagen, ja, bitte benutze jetzt gerade Satellit 5 nicht, weil er hat ein Problem. Bitte nicht benutzen.
Wie schwerwiegend ist denn das, wenn jetzt so einer eiert und einfach falsche Daten liefert bei GPS? Also wirkt sich das unmittelbar sofort exakt auf jeden Fall auf die Positionen aus?
Ja, kann sich auf jeden Fall sofort darauf auswirken. Auf die Genauigkeit oder auf das... Ich meine, wenn die Messagefalte falsche Daten enthält, kann zum Beispiel die Position des Satelliten völlig falsch sein, die man da übertragen kriegt. Also es wirkt sich eigentlich sofort aus. Es ist sehr, sehr gefährlich. Also wenn ich in mein Flugzeug landen will und genau in dem Moment, wo ich lande...
Ja, das ist schon so eine der Sachen, die man doch vielleicht eher verhindern möchte. Okay, also Datenintegrität war das Stichwort.
Das ist einer der wichtigen Punkte für Galileo. Dann natürlich also diese Drei-Frequenz-Möglichkeit, die die Amerikaner erst jetzt so langsam schaffen, die wird Galileo von Anfang an schaffen. Sie werden sogar, also sie haben drei Frequenzbänder, in denen Galileo Signale abstrahlen wird. Damit kann man verschiedene hochgenaue Positionierungen durchführen mit Trägerphasenmessungen. Und das bietet sehr, sehr viel. Man kann die Ionosphäre sehr schön vermessen damit.
Die Ionosphäre selbst?
Also die ionosphärischen Störungen.
Trägerphasen, was war das?
Das misst, das macht man bei sehr hochgenauer Navigation. Man macht diese Laufzeitmessung basierend auf einer Phasenmessung. Also ich gucke mir an, ich habe da einen Träger, wo ich mein Signal aufmoduliere im Satelliten. Das kann man so sehen, das ist eine Art Sinusschwingung. Und ich kann dann feststellen in meinem Empfänger, wie viele Sinusschwingungen passen in den Abstand vom Empfänger zum Satelliten. Und das macht dieser Empfänger, der weiß in der wievielten Schwingung er ist und misst dann den Phasenunterschied. Und mit dieser Trägerphasenmessung kann ich sehr, sehr hochgenau navigieren. Aber man muss da einiges machen, damit man das ordentlich hinbekommt.
Sozusagen auf Schwingungslänge.
Also ich kann dann auf die Wellenlänge des Signals genau auf die Wellenlänge des Signals genau bei Gigahertz ist das ja schon nicht im Zentimeterbereich.
Im Zentimeterbereich.
Also die hochgenauen Empfänger arbeiten mit diesen Trägerphasenmessungen. Zum Beispiel es gibt Platten-Tektoniker, die arbeiten damit, die die Bewegung der Äquatorialplatten verfolgen. Die stellen GPS-Empfänger auf und beobachten die Trägerphasenmessung über sehr, sehr lange Zeiten und können dann eben diese Bewegung aufziehen.
Aber machen das derzeit noch im Meterbereich?
Na, die machen das schon im Zentimeterbereich. Ja, mit GPS.
Ja, wie das denn?
Mit Differential, GPS und allem Drum und Dran.
Okay, aber dann braucht man sozusagen, ja gut, so viele Platten gibt es auch wieder nicht. Also man sucht sich sozusagen die Punkte aus, wo man die GPS hat und steckt dann da einen Stift sozusagen in die Platte und guckt, wie sehr sie sich bewegt. Das heißt so auch für Erdbeben, Vorhersage etc. Aber das ginge dann mit Galileo sozusagen auch ohne die GPS. Also ohne Differential.
Nee, das brauche ich auch. Also um die Ionosphäre zu korrigieren, brauche ich immer diese Differential GPS. Oder eben mit Galileo, wenn ich diese mehreren Frequenzen habe, die aber auch fairerweise GPS in Zukunft haben wird, für zivile Nutzer, wird es dann auch funktionieren.
Gibt es denn irgendwas, was GPS in Zukunft nicht haben wird, was bei Galileo eingebaut wird? Also das wird bei GPS nicht nachgerüstet.
Soweit ich das verfolgt habe, bisher gibt es da keine.
Funktioniert immer sozusagen. Was steckt noch drin im Design von Galileo? Also wie hoch ist denn sozusagen die Nennauflösung? So die normale, ich habe jetzt keine Differenz.
Auch im Meterbereich, aber es ist um einiges besser als der normale GPS Service, den wir jetzt empfangen können.
Also das heißt, die eigentliche Nutzauflösung ist zunächst einmal genauso groß, aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass sie genau ist, also die Schwankung, die ist viel niedriger. Und wodurch wird das erzielt?
Das wird durch höhere Bandbreiten erzielt, die übertragen. Also die Signale haben in der Regel höhere Bandbreiten als bei GPS und durch ein clevereres Signaldesign. Da hat man natürlich auch ein bisschen, man kann am Signal einiges ändern, sodass ich genauere Positionsbestimmungen und genauere Laufzeitmessungen durchführen kann. Und die Amerikaner haben das gemacht basierend auf, ja das System wurde in den 70er Jahren designt und also man hat sich einfach in der Zwischenzeit mehr Gedanken gemacht, was kann man denn da noch verändern und verbessern und das wurde in Galileo schrittweise gemacht.
Und wann kommt es? Also ist ja schon eine Weile unterwegs. Also ich meine, aus welchem Jahr ist das Galileo-Design?
Das Galileo-Design, das ist auch eine gute Frage. Das wurde 1999, glaube ich, begonnen, damit um den Dreh rum wurde, aber das Signal-Design wurde erst vor zwei Jahren vollständig abgeschlossen. Also das ist ein Prozess, der gestartet ist und das System-Design, glaube ich, ist auch erst zwei, drei Jahre wirklich abgeschlossen, befindet sich aber zurzeit im Aufbau und natürlich auch noch im Umbau. Also da findet man natürlich immer noch Dinge, die verbessert werden müssen, die man vielleicht in der Planung nicht alle berücksichtigt hat. Dann gibt es verschiedene andere Probleme noch, die technisch zu lösen sind. Also das System befindet sich noch im Aufbau und in der finalen Entwicklung auch noch in dem Aufbau.
Das heißt, aber es steht jetzt schon fest, so soll es sein.
Ja, das steht fest.
Das ist jetzt sozusagen durch. Es wird jetzt keine nennenswerten Änderungen geben, die sozusagen das Basisdesign verändern. Was findet dann derzeit statt?
Der Aufbau. Also der Aufbau der Bodenstationen, die Produktion der Satelliten. Also da werden die ersten vier Satelliten Ende nächsten Jahres geschossen. Es sind zwei Test-Satelliten jetzt schon im Orbit, wo man auch schon Galileo empfangen kann.
Ende 2011. Mal ein bisschen zukunftsorientiert formulieren.
Ende 2011 kommt die sogenannte In-Orbit-Validation-Phase. Oder die hat schon begonnen, aber da werden dann eben die Satelliten geschossen dazu. Das heißt da mit diesen vier Satelliten, da sind wir wieder bei den vier, mit denen kann ich eine Positionslösung durchführen. Damit wird das System getestet dann. Also das Bodensystem, die ersten Nutzerempfänger werden damit getestet. Das wird jetzt in den nächsten Jahren noch laufen.
Die dann aber auf unterschiedlichen Bahnen unterwegs sind. Das heißt, man hat nur zu bestimmten Zeiten des Tages wirklich mal alle vier im Blick.
Genau, das ist richtig. Da gibt es nur bestimmte Zeiten an bestimmten Orten, wo man dann immer wieder diese vier Satelliten...
Da mal eine Viertelstunde, da mal eine Viertelstunde, und dann ist das Ding wieder weg.
Also ist noch nicht richtig nutzbar.
Ja klar, aber man kann zumindest schon mal gucken, wenn die jetzt sozusagen die vier wären, die ich sehe, und jetzt sehe ich sie halt gerade mal, dann kann man eben auch mal wirklich den Empfänger machen. Hat man nicht irgendwie ein riesiges Problem, damit das GPS einfach schon da ist?
Ja, ja natürlich. Da kommt natürlich immer jeder und fragt, wieso brauchen wir das? Wir haben doch schon. Läuft doch schon.
Das ist unabhängig von dem Brauchen. Ich meine, dass man das haben will und dann, wenn es da ist, das natürlich auch gebrauchen kann, okay. Aber man will ja auch einen hohen Grad an Adoption haben. Man will ja auch, dass es dann benutzt wird, weil es jetzt einfach nur so aus Spaß und Freude hochzuschicken mit einem, naja, jetzt haben wir unser System, das ist total unabhängig. Ja, aber keiner benutzt es, ja auch Quatsch. Was sind denn dann sozusagen die Incentives, um auch wirklich zu einer Nutzung von Galileo zu kommen? Also wer scharrt denn jetzt schon mit den Hufen und möchte gerne Galileo haben, weil es ihm dann ab dem Moment, wo es läuft, auch wirklich das etwas bietet, was derzeit nicht gemacht werden muss.
Also ich denke, die Luftfahrtindustrie scharrt da mit den Hufen. Also die wollen ganz schnell, möglichst schnell diese, wie wir besprochen haben, diese Landung von Flugzeugen mit Satellitennavigation. Da erhoffen die sich große Kostenreduktion. Es gibt auch denke ich einige Leute, also man wird es merken, auch die Leute in der Stadt, die navigieren wollen, werden es merken, weil die Galileo wird mit GPS interoperabel sein. Das heißt, ich empfange GPS-Satelliten und Galileo-Satelliten im gleichen Frequenzband.
Also ein Galileo-Empfangsgerät kann auch GPS empfangen?
Und damit habe ich, wenn ich in meiner Straße mit hohen Häusern stehe, wo ich sehr viel meiner Umgebung abgeschirmt ist, habe ich auf jeden Fall eine größere Wahrscheinlichkeit mehr Satelliten zu sehen, wenn ich zwei Systeme verwenden kann.
Das heißt, er würde quasi alle Satelliten heranziehen für eine Berechnung?
Genau.
Weil die ja im Prinzip auch nichts anderes tun als die GPS.
Man kann das alles verbinden. Da gibt es ein bisschen Probleme um die Zeitskala von GPS mit Galileo, die sind nicht synchronisiert, zu synchronisieren. Aber das kann man alles machen. Der Empfänger ist dazu in der Lage. Und die Systeme werden da auch in ihrer Message eventuell gewisse Daten austauschen, damit der Empfänger das leichter machen kann. Das sind auch wieder Dinge, die in der Message übertragen werden. Und das wird dem Nutzer denke ich auch jedem von uns auf der Straße helfen, dass ich mit meinem iPhone-Telefon hier einfach nicht nur drei Satelliten, vielleicht nicht nur drei Satelliten, sondern vier, fünf sehen kann, dass ich drei GPS, zwei Galileo-Satelliten habe oder ich kann einfach mehr Satelliten sehen und dadurch wird mein Fehler einfach auch geringer. Ja, mit GLONASS kann man das auch schon machen. Da gibt es auch schon lange kombinierte Empfänger. Nur GLONASS ist nicht ganz so interoperabel mit GPS. Also die GLONASS verwendet eine grundlegend andere Technik. Also die verwenden nicht diese CDMA-Technik bisher, sondern die verwenden eine Frequency Division Multiple Access Technik. Das heißt, jeder Satellit hat ein gewisses Frequenzband, wo er drin sitzt und permanent abstrahlt. Und die Empfängertechnik für GLONASS ist also grundlegend verschieden von der von GPS. Und deshalb ist es nicht so ganz so attraktiv gewesen.
Das heißt, Galileo ist auch technisch bewusst an GPS orientiert, um einfach auch eine Kompatibilität der Endgeräte von vornherein zu ermöglichen. In dem Moment, wo Galileo läuft, ist es jetzt für einen Hersteller kein unlösbares Vorhaben, schnell etwas zu machen, was jetzt keinen nennenswerten Mehraufwand hat, abgesehen jetzt natürlich von der ganzen Software, die da erstmal natürlich bewältigt sein muss. Aber jetzt ist es jetzt sozusagen technisch auch nur so der Chip, der empfängt und er sieht dann halt nicht nur GPS, sondern eben auch noch Galileo und kann sich dann eben seinen eigenen Reim daraus machen.
Und dann gibt es eben verschiedene Anwendungen, die natürlich diese Integritätsinformationen gerne haben und unbedingt brauchen. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel meine Züge damit irgendwie besser logistisch ordnen möchte. Bisher ist es ja in solchen riesen Block, da hat man immer einen Block, da fährt der Zug ein, da hat er sein Signal. Und dann gibt es verschiedene Systeme am Boden noch, die die Position des Zuges feststellen können. Aber das ist sehr ungenau, was da bisher verwendet wird. Aber es sind solche speziellen Anwendungen, das nennt man diese sicherheitskritischen Anwendungen. Das klingt jetzt so militärisch, ist aber ein Sicherheits... Also wo ich etwas sehr genau mit hoher Zuverlässigkeit machen möchte. Und diese ganzen Leute, die das machen wollen, die, denke ich, warten sehr, sehr dringend oder mit hoher Erwartung an Galileo. Weil sie das brauchen werden. Sie werden diese Integritätsinformationen bekommen, die sie brauchen, um mit der nötigen Sicherheit diesen Service anbieten zu können. Und wenn sie diese Sicherheit nicht haben, müssen sie eben sehr, sehr viel Aufwand leisten, um mit GPS diese Sicherheit gewährleisten zu können.
Zeigen Sie sich denn das schon ab, dass in dem Moment, wo Galileo läuft, also wann soll denn der letzte, nennenswerte, also der letzte benötigte Satellit offiziell fliegen?
Also für mich ist es unklar. Also die Pläne sind, glaube ich, dass es so bis 2016 vollständig fliegt. Aber das ändert sich schon seit einigen Jahren immer wieder. Ist auch ganz normal für große Raumfahrtprojekte. Die Zeitpläne ändern sich da leider sehr häufig, weil man immer wieder politische, also in Europa auch politische Probleme hat. Man muss immer alle Mitgliedsstaaten unter einen Hut bringen. Die müssen alle immer noch davon begeistert sein. Die müssen immer noch sehen, dass sie alle den gleichen Nutzen davon haben. Und auf der anderen Seite hat man doch immer wieder auch technische Probleme, die man bewältigen muss, auf die man vorher eben nicht durchdacht oder die man vorher eben nicht eingeplant hatte.
Aber unterscheidet sich da Galileo jetzt von anderen Raumfahrtprojekten? Weil ich meine, solche Bedenken und Probleme gibt es ja vermutlich bei jeder Mission.
Also soweit ich, ich habe jetzt noch nicht so viele Missionen verfolgt, aber soweit ich das von Kollegen weiß, die viel in Projekten gearbeitet haben, und ich sage, das ist relativ normal für Raumfahrtprojekte, dass sie relativ viel Verzögerung haben.
Das heißt, das liegt jetzt nicht spezifisch daran, dass es sich hierbei jetzt um Satellitennavigationen handelt. Sondern das ist einfach das Problem, was man einfach hat, dass man so viele Interessen zusammenbringen muss. Ich könnte mir auch vorstellen, dadurch, dass der unmittelbare wirtschaftliche Nutzen natürlich bei einem Satellitennavigationssystem, haben wir ja schon einige Ideen genannt, wo das zum Einsatz kommen könnte, so direkt und eminent ist, dass die Diskussion darüber einfach auch ein bisschen heißer geführt wird als potenzielle Erkenntnisse über Asteroiden, die man vielleicht bei irgendeiner Fernmission bekommen könnte.
Da spielt das nicht so eine Rolle für den Bürger, oder für mich und dich, ob die Sonde so und so zwei Jahre später fliegt oder nicht. Aber bei Galileo, ich finde es auch schön, dass die Öffentlichkeit sich dafür so interessiert, weil das ist eine Infrastrukturmaßnahme für Europa, die sehr, sehr wichtig sein wird für die Zukunft.
2016.
Ja, also mich bitte nicht festnageln und dieses...
Ende 2010, das ist ja jetzt auch so lange gar nicht mehr hin.
Es kommen als nächstes diese vier Satelliten und dann wird aufgerüstet auf 14. Da kommen dann 14 weitere. Das ist die nächste Ausbaustufe und dann geht es hoch auf die 30 später danach.
Und 30, also ähnlich wie bei GPS, das heißt auch da hat man so 28 in Betrieb und zwei fliegen so als Backup mit. Das heißt, man kann sagen, dass GPS in der Hinsicht eigentlich auch schon das Optimum gefunden hat.
Die Bahnen sind anders. Für Galileo sind die Bahnen so optimiert worden, dass der Service über Europa natürlich am besten ist, dass ich da möglichst viele Satelliten gleichzeitig sehe und möglichst häufig in guten Konstellationen. Da gibt es glaube ich nur zwei Bahnen.
Nur zwei anstatt der sechs über GPS?
Drei gibt es, genau. Drei und bei GPS gibt es sechs. Das ist ein bisschen anders organisiert, aber damit der Service über Europa besser ist. Die Amerikaner haben es besser, haben es so optimiert, dass es über Amerika und über dem nördlichen Hemisphäre gut ist. Die Europäer organisieren das ein bisschen anders.
drei Bahnen, das war mehr los auf einer Bahn. Fliegen die Satelliten immer im gleichen Abstand?
Ja, soweit ich weiß, wird der Abstand gehalten.
Und, ähm, mal überlegen, die fliegen da also so rum. Haben die dann auch denselben, also etwa auch denselben Orbit wie GPS? Oder sind die tiefer oder höher?
Ich glaube, sie sind tiefer, aber ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Ja, was mich ja, wo ich jetzt gerne noch mal ein bisschen nachhaken würde, um da noch mal so ein bisschen auch das Hirnenbewegung zu bekommen, ist so mit diesen Anwendungen. Ich meine, jetzt haben wir ja gehört, okay, Integrität, das System kann sagen, ich bin kaputt. Das ist super. Aber das ist ja jetzt erstmal so keine neue Qualität. Also ich meine, es ist eine neue Qualität, aber es hilft mir dann in dem Moment nicht wirklich weiter, weil er sagt mir nur, mit verlasste ich mal nicht auf mich. Aber in dem Moment, wo man sich darauf verlässt und man kann wohl davon ausgehen, dass es die meiste Zeit das sehr wohl tut, dadurch, dass hier gleich mit drei Frequenzen gearbeitet wird und man eben durch diese Phasenauswertungen diese hochgenaue Messung vornehmen kann und dann eben im Zentimeterbereich. Was für Anwendungen sind denn da noch im Gespräch? Es gibt ja da auch ein Marketing für dieses System. Die müssen ja nach außen gehen und sagen hier toll Zentimeterabstand.
Wenn ich mein Auto so genau positionieren möchte, dass ich die Spur detektiere, in welcher Spur ich fahre, dann brauche ich ein Zentimetergenauigkeit. Eine Metergenauigkeit reicht mir da nicht. Da weiß ich nicht, ob ich genau in der Spur fahre.
Das heißt also ein Navigationssystem mit Galileo, was für dich auf Zentimetern basiert. Kann einem auch sagen, du bist auf der richtigen Spur, um jetzt hier rechts abzubiegen.
Ja, und da kann ich eventuell die Finger vom Steuer lassen und das System sagt sich das alleine. Das gleiche ist für die Anwendungen im Zug. Da muss ich auch wissen, auf welchem Gleis ich bin.
Achso, dass man schon im Gleis ist.
Die Information kriegt man nicht über das Satellitennavigationssystem. Aber das ist auch wichtig, da reicht mir Metergenauigkeit nicht aus.
Also sozusagen als Sicherheitssystem. Da hat der Motor hier Weiche falsch gestellt, zack, gleich mal Notbremsung einleiten.
Sie sind hier auf dem falschen Gleis. Ist eventuell, Metergenauigkeit reicht mir hier nicht aus. Beim Flugzeug habe ich die gleiche Geschichte, also da möchte ich am Ende auf mehrere, also da reicht mir eventuell noch eine Metergenauigkeit ein bisschen aus, aber ist schwierig. Ich möchte das Flugzeug in einer Touchbox, die irgendwie 10 mal 10 Meter ist, reinbringen, damit es genau da aufsetzt auf der Landebahn, dass ich da nicht zu weit links, nicht zu weit rechts bin. Ja, da ist es auch wünschenswert, in eine hohe Genauigkeit zu kommen.
Das heißt, man kommt dann so langsam wirklich in dieses vollautomatisierte Landen rein?
Ja, ja, das ist angedacht.
Was heute so noch gar nicht...
Es gibt ein teilautomatisiertes Landen, soweit ich das weiß.
Ein teilautomatisiertes, aber das ist halt schon immer noch die Hand am Knüppel.
Ja, die Hand ist am Knüppel. Die wollen bis zum Touchdown, dass der Pilot bloß nichts mehr berührt. Die machen immer nur alles kaputt. Ja, die erhoffen sich. So habe ich es verstanden. Die Airlines erhoffen sich dadurch längere Wartungsintervalle, weil die Vertrauen, die sagen, der Pilot macht Fehler, das System macht die weniger Fehler.
Und der Klassiker, die Schiffe? Ich habe gehört, dass manche Schiffe auch schon mit mehreren Empfängern gleichzeitig ausgestattet sind.
Da geht es darum, dass man eben versucht, Genauigkeit zu erhöhen, weil ich lokale Effekte habe. Ich habe eventuell mehrere Empfänger auch an meinem Schiff, weil ich nicht genau weiß, was habe ich da für Ausbreitungscharakteristiken und ich möchte dann einfach über die Fehler praktisch sozusagen mitteln. Ich habe dann mehrere Empfänger, die mir eine Information liefern und ich möchte da Robustheit erreichen. Robustheit? Ja, wenn einer der Empfänger leicht abweicht von allen anderen und die anderen sind ungefähr im gleichen Wert, dann weiß ich, oh, mit dem einen stimmt irgendwas nicht.
Sozusagen um eine Ausfallsicherheit der Empfänger sicherzustellen.
Ja, aber auch um, es kann in der Nahumgebung der Empfänger irgendwas passieren, so dass ich irgendeine besondere Mehrwege- Ausbreitung hab, die erhöht dann auch meinen Fehler. Und da, wenn ich mehrere Empfänger gleichzeitig beobachte, kann ich eben solche Fehler auch sehen durch mehrere Empfänger. Was wir viel machen hier ist, dass wir Empfänger benutzen mit mehreren Antennen. Da kann ich dann noch räumlich mein Signal, also da hatten wir am Anfang drüber gesprochen, dass wir mit dem normalen Empfänger keine räumliche Orientierung des Signals feststellen können. Wenn ich jetzt mehrere Antennen habe an einem Empfänger, dann kann ich das. Dann kann ich praktisch im Raum abtasten an verschiedenen Orten und kann dann eben auch feststellen, wo kommt denn mein Signal her. Und ich kann auch räumlich dann filtern.
Man kann also auf diese kurze Distanz noch unterscheiden, ob das Signal an einer einen Antenne vor einer anderen Antenne ankommt?
Das kann man machen.
Da reicht aber die Nanosekunde schon nicht mehr aus.
Nein, aber das macht man über Phasendifferenzen. Das macht man nicht über Laufzeitunterschiede. Genau aus diesem Grund nimmt man an, dass diese Laufzeitunterschiede sehr, sehr klein sind. Aber die Phasenunterschiede, da bin ich im halben Wellenlängenabstand wieder ungefähr unterwegs. Also kleiner als eine halbe Wellenlänge sind die Antennen auseinander dann.
Was ist die Wellenlänge?
Kleiner als eine halbe Wellenlänge. Die ist bei L1 19 cm. Also ich bin dann hier bei 10, 10, gut 10 cm Abstand, ungefähr neuneinhalb.
Okay, das heißt also ein Gerät mit mehreren Antennen müsste sozusagen mindestens diese 10 cm Abstand haben zwischen den Antennen. Dass man auch wirklich zuverlässig sagen kann, hier ist eine Phase mehr verwendet worden als da. Also kam es da zu spät ein.
Die müssen kleiner als die halbe Wellenlänge sein, die Abstände. Sonst habe ich mehr Deutlichkeiten. Sonst weiß ich nicht mehr, wie viele Wellenlängen dazwischen liegen. Und mit diesen Mehrantennenempfängern kann ich viele dieser lokalen Effekte sehr, sehr gut unterdrücken. Also Mehrwegeausbreitung, ich kann auch Interferenzen unterdrücken, weil ich kann feststellen, aus welcher Richtung kommt das? Ist das mein gewünschtes Signal oder nicht? Und kann dann so eine erräumliche Filterung machen.
Heißt das, dass die Antennen immer so im Kreis angeordnet sind?
Die können beliebig angeordnet sein. Der Kreis ist nett, man kann es im Quadrat aufstellen.
Und wie viel braucht man so, dass man da wirklich eine zuverlässige...
Also vier wären schon ganz nett, denke ich.
Aber könnten auch mehr sein.
Ja, das kann mehr sein.
Umso mehr, umso besser.
Wir untersuchen diese Prinzipien genau für diese sicherheitskritischen Anwendungen, wo ich nämlich an meinem Empfänger sehr, sehr sicher sein möchte, dass ich keine Mehrwegeausbreitung empfange und dadurch Fehler einfange.
Mehrwegeausbreitung haben wir so noch, glaube ich, gar nicht genau erklärt. Das ist jetzt sozusagen Reflektion am Haus. Solche Geschichten.
Ja.
Wird denn dieser Frequenzbereich von so vielen Materialien gut reflektiert?
Anscheinend schon, ja.
Anscheinend?
Ja, so die...
Weiß man das nicht genau? Was ist das? So Glas oder Stein auch oder Metall?
Ja, hauptsächlich Metall, Glas, glatte Flächen. Und dann eben mit dem... Ja, es kommt immer auf diese Materialeigenschaften an. Aber man hat da schon sehr, sehr starke Echoes von Hauswänden.
Das heißt, in dem Moment, wo ich quasi so einen Mehr wege, also es kann ja dann... Ich kriege ja dann sozusagen von einem Satelliten das Signal mehrfach.
Ja.
Weil ich kriege sowohl sozusagen direkt und ich bekomme es einmal um die Ecke.
Genau.
Und dadurch, dass ich mit mehreren Antennen messe, kann ich jetzt sagen, ah, der kam aber hier von links nach schräg, aber der Satellit hat ja eigentlich gesagt, dass er da oben ist. ZB das muss ich eigentlich alles aus dem Signal herausrechnen. Aber ich weiß es vielleicht so in etwa.
Ja, man weiß es. Also wenn ich meine Position einmal so ein bisschen gekannt, also man kann ein bisschen was machen.
Also das ist mehr so eine Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung an der Stelle. Dass man sagt, das kann jetzt eigentlich nicht das richtige Signal sein, weil er müsste ja eigentlich da sein, weil vorhin war er da ja auch. Und jetzt kommt hier auf einmal dieses Teil rein und will mir irgendwie meine Berechnung verhageln, den ignoriere ich jetzt einfach.
Genau, geh weg, blockier ich einfach, da nagel ich ein Brett davor und dann kommt er nicht mehr.
Püffig, das heißt, man gewinnt dadurch jetzt nicht im eigentlichen Sinne mehr Auflösung. Diese Auflösung ist eigentlich festgelegt durch diese Frequenz und durch diese Phase. Also es ist halt einfach dieser Zentimeter, aber wenn die Wellenlänge 10 cm ist, wie kann man da eine Zentimetergenauigkeit rausrechnen?
Man kommt dann runter, man misst diese Phase. Wenn ich weiß, ich bin in dieser Wellenlänge, dann ist eine Wellenlänge 20 cm. Da kann ich beliebig reindeuten, es ist völlig egal, ich bin immer im Zentimeterbereich mit meinem Fehler. Wo jetzt genau der Abstand in dieser letzten Wellenlänge ist.
Das heißt, mit diesem Mehrwege-Ausschlussverfahren kann ich Empfänger bauen, die einfach gegen Einflüsse, insbesondere in so kritischen urbanen Gebieten, besonders resistent sind. Sodass man sich eben auch hier nicht nur auf die Aussage des Systems, wie gut es selbst funktioniert, verlassen kann, sondern dass ich auch eine Aussage über die Qualität des Empfangs treffen kann, beziehungsweise von vornherein ausschließen kann, dass mir da irgendwas die Berechnung verhagelt. Das heißt, ich hab nicht nur jetzt einen Zentimeter, der errechnet wurde, sondern ich weiß auch, der stimmt. Und wo braucht man das?
Also das braucht man zum Beispiel für diese Referenzstationen an Flughäfen, unserer Meinung nach.
Die Planentettonik hätte auch ganz gerne.
Die Leute könnten das vielleicht auch brauchen, aber dann geht es halt, wenn ich Schiffe navigieren möchte, große Maschinen, also Bagger, Holzerntemaschinen. Da sitzen teilweise Leute drin, die im Wald rumfahren und die wollen einen Baum finden, den der Förster markiert hat, den sie jetzt fällen sollen. Und der Mann in der Maschine weiß aber meistens nicht, wo der Baum ist. Und damit er nicht ewig im Wald rumgrauchen muss und diesen Baum sucht, hat er seinen Navigationsempfänger und kann dann direkt da hinfahren mit möglichst wenig Zerstörung.
Aber gerade im Wald hat man doch überhaupt gar keinen Sichtkontakt.
Genau, da kommen jetzt auch diese Mehrantennensysteme, die eigentlich da einen großen Vorteil bieten, weil je mehr Antennen ich hab, desto stärker kann ich auch meinen, ich kann praktisch meinen Signal stärker empfangen, weil ich durch diese Mehrantennen kann ich die Richtcharakteristik meiner Antenne in Richtung des Satelliten verstärken, weil ich praktisch einen Filter ausbilde in diese Richtung, kann mein Ohr vergrößern und damit habe ich auch im Wald bessere Möglichkeiten, genauer zu navigieren.
Das ist irgendwie teuer.
Das ist teuer, groß, macht viel Spaß daran zu arbeiten, weil es kompliziert ist. Aber wir müssen nur warten, wie alle Dinge, das ist hauptsächlich eine Sache, die im Digitalen passiert. Man hat natürlich mehrere Antennen, dafür muss man mehr Geld ausgeben.
Aber die Antennen sind nicht im einigsten Sinne das teurere.
Nein, dann hat man die Empfangs-Hardware, die muss man halt vervielfachen. Aber das sind Dinge, die nicht besonders teuer sind. Natürlich im Mobilfunk-Bereich, da spielt jeder Cent eine Rolle, ob ich etwas verkaufe oder nicht. Aber über die Anwendungen, wo wir jetzt gerade drüber gesprochen haben, da spielt es eigentlich keine Rolle, ob der Empfänger ein paar tausend Euro mehr oder weniger kostet, weil das Gesamtprodukt schon so teuer ist, da spielt es keine Rolle. Und das bietet natürlich eine Menge Sicherheit.
Wo der Nutzen auch so groß ist, echt einen einzelnen Baum finden, das ist auch wirklich krass.
Und dann geht es darum, die wollen riesige Bagger in Minen und an Großbaustellen über 24 Stunden laufen lassen, auch in der Nacht, und da ordentlich navigieren. Das sind so Anwendungen, die wir schon so...
Das heißt, was so wirklich auch dahinter steht, unter anderem ist auch ein hohes Maß an Maschinenautomatisierung. Das ist sozusagen das letzte, was wir jetzt noch so brauchen, um so richtig so einen Maschinenarmada da übers Land fahren zu lassen. Na, da werden sie ja wieder alle schreien wegen der Rationalisierung.
Da muss schon noch einer in der Maschine sitzen, aber der weiß dann wenigstens ganz genau, wo er ist und er kurvt nicht irgendwo. Also das sind so logistische Probleme auch. Wie das auch im Hafen, wenn ich Container organisieren will, da kann ich auch mit differenziellem GPS und solchen, da könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass man auch solche Mehrentennensysteme braucht. Weil zum Beispiel, ich glaube in Rotterdam ist es, da fahren diese Laster, die die Container transportieren, die fahren automatisch, da sitzt keiner mehr drin. Die fahren jetzt zur Zeit an so Boden, die orientieren sich an Kabeln oder, ich glaube es sind irgendwelche Metallstreifen, die im Boden eingebaut sind. Damit können sie aber nur auf diesen vorgegebenen Routen fahren, sind ein bisschen eingeschränkt. Wenn man das Ganze natürlich mit GPS oder mit Zatellitennavigation macht, dann könnte man sozusagen schon so ein Ameisen-gleiches Gewusel organisiert bekommen.
Auch auf Flughäfen.
Völlig beliebig dann. Man braucht keine Führungsschienen und nichts.
So ein beruhigendes Gefühl gibt, wenn man dann aus seinem Flugzeug schaut nach der Landung. Alle fahren mit Vollkaracho aufeinander zu, treffen sich aber nie, weil sie sozusagen auf den Zentimeter in ihrer Bahn rausgehen.
Ich wäre da beruhigter.
Das kann nur der Ingenieur sagen.
Ich war als Kind eines dieser Kinder, was öfter mal bei der Landung im Cockpit war. Auch danach. Und jedes Mal ziehen die Piloten einen Plan raus. Wo müssen wir denn jetzt hin zum Gate so und so? Ach, bieg doch hier mal ab. Dann sind sie wieder mit ihrer Bodenkontrolle in Kontakt. Ja, wir biegen jetzt bei Punkt so und so rechts ab. Und dann sagt er, ja, gut. Ich hab das mehrfach so als Kind in Erinnerung, dass das so war. Vielleicht ist es heute anders. Es ist ja auch schon ein bisschen her. Aber das sind solche Dinge, die, denke ich, verbessert werden können. Und auch gerade diese Taxing-Organisation, da wird viel drüber gesprochen, dass man da optimieren muss. Und ich glaube, ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass das heute noch so ist. Ist nicht schlimm, die fahren halt da so rum. Da passiert auch nichts. Es gibt eine Bodenkontrolle, die das im Griff haben, wer da wo rumfährt. Nur ich denke, die Ordnung kann man sicherlich verbessern.
Ist denn bei Galileo dann auch sozusagen jede Auflösung für jedermann verfügbar?
Ja.
Das heißt, es gibt da keine gesperrten Bereiche?
Es gibt einen Public Regulated Service, der nicht für alle zugänglich sein wird, der eine sehr hohe Auflösung bietet. Aber es gibt einen offenen Service, der eine wesentlich höhere Bandbreite sogar hat, wenn man den nutzen möchte.
Das heißt, Zentimeter ist jetzt nicht für jeden?
Zentimeter ist für jeden. Wenn ich diese Trägerphasenmessungen mache, die kann jeder machen.
Was kann der Public Regulated Service noch mehr?
Der hat höhere Störsicherheit. Es gibt viele Störsignale. Manche Satellitennavigationssystem-Bänder teilen sich ein Band mit anderen Services, zum Beispiel mit militärischen Radarsystemen, teilweise mit Luftfahrtsystemen, die die Distanz zum Flughafen mit dem Flugzeug ausmessen. Es gibt verschiedene andere Störeinflüsse, die teilweise über höhere harmonische aus anderen Bändern kommen, die in die zwar teilweise geschützten Bänder trotzdem Störungen einbringen. Wenn ich diese Störungen loswerden will, dann brauche ich gewisse Eigenschaften im Signal. Dieser Public Regulated Service bietet da sehr, sehr gute Eigenschaften. Hauptsächlich ist es Bandbreite. Das ist einer der Services, der sehr, sehr viel Bandbreite braucht.
An welcher Stelle entsteht dieser Service? Ich benutze ja nicht andere Satelliten und kriege ja auch keine anderen Informationen von diesen Satelliten.
Ach so, Galileo ist so eingerichtet, ich habe verschiedenste Signale, also nicht nur drei in diesen drei Frequenzbändern, sondern ich habe fünf Services, glaube ich. Wir haben verschiedene Services und diesen Services sind verschiedene Signale zugeordnet.
Was kann man sich das Service vorstellen?
Es gibt einen sogenannten Open Service. Da gibt es zwei Frequenzbänder, die ich dafür verwenden kann.
Das ist sozusagen wie GPS?
Ja, und das sind zwei Signale, die ich da empfangen kann. Dann gibt es einen sogenannten Safety of Life Service, das sind eben für diese sicherheitskritischen Anwendungen. Da heißt die Message anders designed. Da kann ich auch zwei Signale empfangen, auf zwei verschiedenen Frequenzbändern, die speziell für diesen Service, also speziell für sicherheitskritische Anwendungen zur Verfügung stehen. Dann gibt es noch einen sogenannten Commercial Service. Da möchte man höhere Integritätssicherheit bieten, indem man hier, da war früher mal angedacht, sogar Gebühren zu verlangen für diesen Service. Ich weiß nicht, wie da jetzt der Stand augenblicklich ist. Da ist so, da hätte man dann zum Beispiel auch wirklich sagen können, ja, ich habe da, ich will diesen Service nutzen und ich kriege auch eine vom Service, vom System so eine Art Garantie, dass ich den nutzen kann. Das ist nicht für die anderen Services so gegeben. Und dann gibt es noch den Public Regulated Service. Also haben wir nur vier, ja. Der ist für hoheitliche Aufgaben definiert worden. Also für Polizei, Feuerwehr, Katastrophenschutz, aber auch für militärische Anwendungen. Und da geht es natürlich auch drum. Ich meine, klar, in so Katastrophenzeiten kann es sein, dass bestimmte Services auch eventuell nicht zur Verfügung stehen oder bewusst abgeschaltet werden. Und da bleibt dann eben nur dieser Public Regulated Service übrig als der, der für die, die jetzt das wirklich nur noch brauchen, funktionsbereit ist.
Und das ist abgesichert durch kryptographische Methoden.
Ja, das heißt, nicht jeder Zugriff.
Das heißt, letzten Endes läuft das alles über den Empfänger. Der Empfänger hat eine Lizenz für irgendeinen dieser Dienste. Dementsprechend berechnet sich dann wahrscheinlich auch die Nutzungsabgaben, die dann auch zurück in das Galileo-Konsortium zurückfließen.
Genau, die waren nur angedacht für diesen Commercial Service. Sonst ist alles frei und offen zugänglich.
Na gut, dann ist natürlich die Frage, warum, da schaltet man jetzt noch diese anderen drei Services, wenn die sowieso jedem kostenlos sind?
Also ja, der PRS ist natürlich, der Public Regulated Service ist natürlich auch nicht jedem zugänglich. Da brauche ich, da bin ich codiert, da muss ich mich anmelden bei einer Autorität, die diese Schlüssel vergibt, um ranzukommen.
Aber diese Schlüssel sind im Gerät, die sind jetzt nicht an Personen zugeordnet. Man muss da jetzt nicht noch eine Chipkarte reinstecken und sagen, ich darf das benutzen.
Die sind in den Geräten drin, ja. Aber die anderen Services, da sind die Schlüssel sozusagen, also diese Codes bekannt.
Aber warum unterscheidet man die dann auch noch?
Man unterscheidet die noch einfach, weil die sich in der Message unterscheiden. Also ich hab verschiedene Signale, die einen unterschiedlichen Inhalt der Navigationsnachricht haben.
Aber werden nicht sowieso alle Geräte, alle diese Services unterstützen?
Nein, sicherlich nicht. Also ein Mobilfunk, ein mobiles Telefon wird sicherlich nicht den Safety of Life Service nutzen. Warum? Weil die Bandbreiten zu groß sind und dadurch die Komplexität sehr groß wird.
Okay, also die Services stellen andere Anforderungen an die Empfänger sozusagen. Das heißt, man muss auch hardware-technisch einen größeren Aufwand treiben, um die überhaupt nutzen zu können. Aber wenn ich diesen treiben möchte, dann kann ich im Prinzip alle drei Services nutzen, außer den Public Regulated Service. Und wer nutzt den?
Den nutze Polizei, Feuerwehr, Katastrophenschutz, das THW, glaube ich, ist da in Deutschland im Gespräch und eben auch die Bundeswehr.
Und das heißt, die kriegen jetzt in dem Sinne, also ist da jetzt auch noch eine andere Dienstleistung technisch mit drin, außer der, dass es vielleicht noch funktioniert, wenn die anderen nicht mehr funktionieren? Oder können die dann auch noch irgendwas? Also ist da sozusagen auch irgendeine Fähigkeit jetzt für die Feuerwehr da noch mit eingebaut, die man sonst nicht braucht?
Nein, nein.
Das nicht. Also ist sozusagen eher so ein Verfügbarkeitsfeature.
Und das ist halt der Zugang begrenzt ist.
Aber wenn man den Schlüssel hat, dann ist man sozusagen dabei. Also das Gerät als solches kann das. Jetzt haben wir immer nur über die Erde gesprochen. Ich meine, wenn die so 25.000 km entfernt sind, dann ist ja da, bevor das auf der Erde aufschlägt, auch noch so allerlei sonstiges Material da drin. Können denn jetzt auch andere Raumflugkörper aus diesem Satelliten-Navigationssystem irgendeinen Nutzen ziehen?
Ja, also es wird auch im All navigiert mit Satelliten-Navigation. Lustigerweise auch oberhalb der GPS-Orbits. Also für die geostationären Satelliten auch. Die benutzen dann das Signal, was von der anderen Seite der Erde an der Erde vorbei gestrahlt ist. Die hören einfach mit. Die hören das von der anderen Seite. Die haben auch GPS-Empfänger an Bord, viele, und die können damit ihre Position auch bestimmen. Natürlich alles, was drunter liegt.
Dann läuft das andersrum. Aber wenn die geostationär sind, dann sehen die doch eigentlich die ganze Zeit, ich meine, das ist auch sowieso stationär. Was müssen die sich noch groß positionieren?
Die bewegen sich. Die bleiben nicht fix in ihrem Orbit stehen. Die müssen immer wieder korrigiert werden. Sonst driften sie auch weg. Dieser Punkt, das Massengleichgewicht, die Anziehung, dass sich das genau ausgleicht, der existiert nur theoretisch.
Ja, richtig. Die Erde ist ja auch da nicht gleichförmig. Cool, das heißt, diese permanent sich ändernden Massen, etc., unterschiedliche Gravitation, die letzten Endes ausgewirkt wird, führt dann zu einer Bahnabweichung. Das heißt, diese Satelliten sind dadurch, dass sie den Bodenstationen die ganze Zeit zuhören und sagen, oh, es hat sich das aber, was weiß ich, die Laufzeit, ich bin jetzt, was weiß ich, 10-15 Minuten.
Denn die kriegen vom Satelliten, der auf der anderen Seite der Erde gerade sein Signal abstrahlt. Das geht an der Erde praktisch außen so vorbei. Und dann kriegen sie es auch noch nicht.
Verstehe, das heißt, sie gucken sozusagen links und rechts an den, es ist gar nicht die Bodenstation, mit dem sie kommunizieren, sondern die anderen Satelliten, die aber, aha, und die strahlen dann so, okay. Aber ich dachte, die strahlen eh nur direkt die Erde an.
Ja, so ganz funktioniert es nicht. Sie können, sie versuchen, die Hauptenergie auf die Erde zu bringen.
Okay, aber es geht dann immer noch ein bisschen was vorbei.
Es wird ein bisschen was verschüttet da.
Und von diesem Spill holen die sich sozusagen dann so ihren Teil ab und können dann zumindest zuverlässig sagen, also wenn euer GPS richtig funktioniert, dann bin ich jetzt gerade mal 10 cm zu weit. Na ja, 10 cm.
Genau, jetzt bitte korrigiert mich mal hier.
Aber so genau können die das, dann glaube ich auch nicht. Ich meine, was für eine Abweichung kann man an der Position denn da noch?
Also ich habe Ergebnisse im Zentimeterbereich gesehen.
Wirklich?
Ja, ja.
36.000 Kilometer von der Erde entfernt.
Ich habe Ergebnisse von der NASA gesehen, die da...
Und dann nochmal 25.000 Kilometer nochmal in die andere Richtung.
Die im Zentimeterbereich da operieren.
Gute Güte. 50.000 Kilometer entfernt und er kann sagen, dass er irgendwie einen Zentimeter zu weit draußen ist.
Ja, das habe ich gesehen.
Das ist ja Raketentechnologie.
Und auf dem Mond? Ja, das ist sehr nett. Da habe ich Kollegen von der NASA einen schönen Vortrag gehalten. Die wollen auch auf dem Mond mit GPS navigieren.
Aber ohne jetzt ein eigenes Mond-GPS aufzubauen. Also, die schicken da jetzt nicht noch...
Ne, ne, die wollen mit dem, mit diesem, was verschüttet wird, mit dieser Reststrahlung da auf dem Mond navigieren. Die hatten jetzt ein Problem, dass sie da anscheinend zu hauptsächlich nur drei Satelliten wirklich permanent sehen können. Und die hoffen, die waren sehr nett. Die haben auch gesagt, ja, wir hoffen auch auf Galileo und dass Galileo auch Energie an der Erde vorbeischickt, weil wir würden dann gerne diese Galileo-Satelliten, die wir dann auch noch sehen können, in unsere Missionsplanung mit einbeziehen.
Ah, die hätten das gerne, dass es nicht so genau ist sozusagen.
Die brauchen noch ein, zwei Satelliten, um dann auf dem Mond wirklich navigieren zu können oder in der Nähe vom Mond navigieren zu können.
Aber das funktioniert dann sozusagen auch nur auf der Erde zugewandten Seite.
Ja, auf der anderen Seite wird es schwierig.
Na gut, aber da ist das Interesse eh nicht so groß. Da zu arbeiten, weil es ein bisschen kalt ist. Ich bin überrascht zu hören, dass das jetzt wirklich auch schon so ein Feature ist, auf das sich die Satellitbetreiber in gewisser Hinsicht auch verlassen. Also ist das so das primäre System, aus dem diese Abweichungen berechnet werden?
Da bin ich ein bisschen überfragt. Ich weiß, dass das auch über Laser-Reflektoren funktioniert. Das heißt, man hat einen Laser, mit dem man auf den Satelliten zeigt. Der hat einen Reflektor und man misst den Abstand zum Satelliten über das reflektierte Licht. Da gibt es solche Sachen. Ich weiß, dass auf den Galileo-Satelliten immer noch solche Reflektoren drauf sind. Das heißt, man möchte auch noch durch diese Methode die Positionen bestimmen können und die Orbits bestimmen können. Ich denke, dass viele Satelliten das einfach noch als Zusatz dabei haben.
Ja, jetzt sind wir schon weit vorgerückt hier im All. Haben wir noch einen ganz wichtigen Aspekt nicht erwähnt. Der soll in dem Zusammenhang auf jeden Fall noch mal genannt werden sollte. Nicht, dass sich einer beschwert.
Er beschwert sich ganz sicherlich jemand.
Ja, sind auch alle zu eingeladen, sich hier zu beschweren, wenn was falsch war oder was...
Oh ja, da war bestimmt irgendwas...
.irgendwas unklar ist. Es stehen ja auch die Kommentare offen im Blog, raumzeitpodcast.de. Ihr seid mal eingeladen da mal reinzuschauen und euer Feedback zu geben zu der Sendung. Ist auch gern gesehen. Auch Fragen stellen. Du guckst da auch nochmal rein.
Ich beantworte dann noch die restlichen Fragen.
Also, haben wir's?
Ja, glaub schon.
Nee, aber das war jetzt auf jeden Fall ein guter Flug. Ich hab jetzt auch doch ein deutlich besseres Verständnis davon, was ich alles tun müsste, wenn ich ein Navigationssatellit wäre.
Da hätte man einiges zu tun.
Auf jeden Fall muss man da viel funken, viel fliegen.
Danke auch.
Das war eine tolle Ausführung hier über Satellitennavigation. Die achte Ausgabe von Raumzeit, aber nicht die letzte. Hier geht es weiter und wir haben noch ein paar andere spannende Themen. Rund ums All hier für euch parat. Ich verrate mal nichts, weil die nächste Sendung kommt bestimmt und dann seid ihr auch ausreichend überrascht. Also, vielen Dank. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und tschüss und bis bald bei Raumzeit.